This episode is brought to you by Lloyds, which has been backing British ambition for over 250 years. Now, when you think about it, every dynasty in history has boiled down to two important elements, aspiration and action. And a classic example of this from British history, the rise of the House of Wessex, the family of Alfred the Great and his heirs, who between them established the United Kingdom of England. Yeah, it's a great story, isn't it? Tom. A great lesson in leadership, I think, for anybody. So Alfred and his heirs, they marry idealism and pragmatism.
本期节目由劳埃德银行（Lloyds）赞助播出，该银行已支持英国的雄心壮志超过250年。说起来，历史上每一个王朝归根结底都离不开两个重要元素：抱负与行动。英国历史上一个典型的例子就是威塞克斯王朝的崛起，阿尔弗雷德大帝及其继承人的家族，他们共同建立了英格兰联合王国。没错，这是一个伟大的故事，不是吗？汤姆。我认为这对任何人来说都是一堂伟大的领导力课程。所以，阿尔弗雷德和他的继承人们，他们将理想主义与实用主义结合在了一起。
They're brilliant at alliances. They're brilliant at managing power. They're brilliance, of course, at managing their money, which is a key part of political leadership. And, of course, we are all reaping the rewards of their wisdom and foresight. When it's time to make your next move, you can bank on Lloyds to be ready. when you are. Because from new businesses to new homes and new life chapters, backed by generations
他们擅长结盟，擅长驾驭权力。当然，他们也擅长理财，这是政治领导力的关键部分。当然，我们都在享受他们智慧和远见的成果。当您需要做出下一个重大决策时，您可以信赖劳埃德银行，随时为您准备。因为从新企业到新家园，再到人生的新篇章，在几代人的支持下，
of hope and ambition, you can see, Tom, why 14 million people trust Lloyd's to help make their dreams a reality. Based on Lloyd's internal customer data from March 26. is ended. Our exultation begins. The border has been crossed. The cannon roars. The earth smokes. The Adriatic is as grey at this hour as the torpedo boat that cuts across it. Companions! Can it be true? We are fighting with arms. We are waging our war. The blood is sparting from the veins of Italy. We are the last to join this struggle, and already the first are meeting with glory. The slaughter begins, the destruction begins.
怀揣着希望与抱负，汤姆，您就能明白为什么1400万人信任劳埃德银行，帮助他们实现梦想。基于劳埃德银行3月26日的内部客户数据。结束了。我们的欢呼开始了。边界已被跨越。大炮轰鸣。大地冒烟。此时的亚得里亚海，正如那艘横穿它的鱼雷艇一样灰暗。同伴们！这是真的吗？我们正在武装战斗。我们正在发动战争。鲜血正从意大利的血管中喷涌而出。我们是最后加入这场斗争的人，但第一批人已经迎来了荣耀。屠杀开始了，毁灭开始了。
One of our people has died at sea, another on land. All of these people, who yesterday thronged in the streets and squares, loudly demanding war, are full of veins, full of bones, full of, blood, and their blood begins to flow. We have no other value but that of our blood to be shed. So that was the poet Gabrielle de Dancio with a frankly lunatic peroration. And he's addressing at Myra's at dawn on the 26th of May 1915. And he's absolutely ecstatic at the news that Italy's soldiers have just fired their first shots and taken their first casualties after joining the First World War. And you would think that by May 1915 he would have worked out that joining the First
我们的人民中，有人死于海上，有人死于陆地。所有这些昨天还在街头巷尾高呼战争的人，他们浑身是血管，浑身是骨头，浑身是血，而他们的血开始流淌。除了我们即将流出的鲜血，我们别无价值。以上是诗人加布里埃尔·邓南遮那番坦率地说近乎疯狂的演讲。他是在1915年5月26日黎明时分在米拉马雷发表的演讲。当得知意大利士兵刚刚打响第一枪并出现首次伤亡的消息时，他感到无比狂喜。你可能会认为，到了1915年5月，他应该已经意识到加入第一次
World War maybe isn't a brilliant idea, but not a bit of it. He is all over it. And to quote Mark Thompson in his brilliant book, The White War on Italy's role in the First World War, has any artist played a more baleful part in decisions that led to violence and suffering on the largest scale? So, Dominic, are you a fan of Danzio? I absolutely despise Donogio, to be honest with you. I think he's one of the worst people we've ever done on the rest of history. And his lunatic rhetoric, as you correctly described it, will have terrible consequences for hundreds of thousands of young Italians. But I'll tell you someone who likes it. Yeah, go on. Is Benito Mussolini, a Italian journalist who may go on to better things in due course?
世界大战可能不是个好主意，但事实并非如此。他对此热衷至极。引用马克·汤普森在他那本关于意大利在第一次世界大战中角色的杰作《白色战争》中的话：还有哪位艺术家在导致大规模暴力和苦难的决策中扮演过如此恶劣的角色？那么，多米尼克，你是邓南遮的粉丝吗？老实说，我绝对鄙视邓南遮。我认为他是我们在《历史的余味》中讲过的最糟糕的人之一。他那如你所描述的疯狂言论，将给成千上万的意大利年轻人带来可怕的后果。但我可以告诉你一个喜欢他的人。是的，请说。那就是贝尼托·墨索里尼，一位意大利记者，他后来可能会有更好的发展。
Higher things, exactly. Yes. And actually, we will be talking about Donunzio and Benito Mussolini, who learns a lot from Donizio later in this episode. But let's just explain what today's episode is all about. So we're in the middle of this great series, epic series, about the year 1915. And this is the story of one of the bloodiest, the cruelest, the most savage of all the campaigns of the First World War. And this is the attempt by the Italians to invade the Austro-Hungarian Empire and to carve out a little empire for themselves on the Adriatic. And it was fought in conditions that were unlike anywhere else in the war. So it's this sort of jagged limestone peaks and these sort of deep river valleys in what is now
更高的成就，没错。是的。事实上，我们稍后会在本期节目中讨论邓南遮和贝尼托·墨索里尼，后者从邓南遮那里学到了很多。但让我们先解释一下今天节目的主题。我们正处于关于1915年的伟大系列、史诗系列节目中。这是第一次世界大战中最血腥、最残酷、最野蛮的战役之一的故事。这是意大利人试图入侵奥匈帝国，并在亚得里亚海为自己开辟一个小帝国的尝试。这场战争的条件在战争中是独一无二的。这里有锯齿状的石灰岩山峰和深邃的河流峡谷，位于现在的
Slovenia, which was then part of the Austro-Hungarian Empire. And it's also, I think, the most obviously acquisitive of the First World War's campaigns. Yeah. I mean, it's completely cynical, isn't it? You know, most people in the First World War believe, as we've talked about many times, when we've talked about this war on the show, most people believe they're fighting in defense of their native land. They think the principle is on their side, that their native land is encircled by enemies.
斯洛文尼亚，当时是奥匈帝国的一部分。而且，我认为这也是第一次世界大战中表现得最明显的掠夺性战役。是的。我的意思是，这完全是愤世嫉俗的，不是吗？你知道，正如我们在节目中多次讨论过的那样，第一次世界大战中的大多数人认为，他们是在保卫自己的祖国。他们认为正义站在他们这一边，他们的祖国被敌人包围了。
I mean, it could be the French, could be the Germans, could be the Austrians. and that they are fighting in defence of hearth and home. The Italians are absolutely open about the fact. They're not defending themselves at all. They're trying to attack other people. And they're fighting for conquest and for glory and for a greater Italy. And the ironic result, the blackly ironic result, is one of the greatest disasters in Italian history.
我的意思是，可能是法国人，可能是德国人，也可能是奥地利人，他们是在为保卫家园而战。而意大利人则毫不掩饰这样一个事实：他们根本不是在自卫。他们是在试图攻击别人。他们是为了征服、为了荣耀、为了一个更伟大的意大利而战。而讽刺的结果，极其讽刺的结果，是意大利历史上最大的灾难之一。
So it ends with a million Italians dead, a million wounded, and a national sense, even though they do get some territory, there's this national sense of betrayal and resentment that plays an enormous part in the rise of fascism in the 1920s. So it's an extraordinary story. It's probably not as well known in the English-speaking world as some other aspects of the First World War. But you mentioned Mark Thompson's book, The White War.
最终导致一百万意大利人死亡，一百万人受伤，尽管他们确实获得了一些领土，但这种民族背叛感和怨恨感在20世纪20年代法西斯主义的兴起中发挥了巨大作用。所以这是一个非凡的故事。在英语世界中，它可能不如第一次世界大战的其他方面那样广为人知。但你提到了马克·汤普森的书《白色战争》。
Yeah, it's an amazing book, isn't it? It's a wonderful book. I've got to be honest, it's the only book on the topic I've read, but I've felt having read it, I didn't need to read anymore. I think that's fair because there's not that many books on this in English. So let's start with Italy. I mean, as you said, Italy was not in the First World War at the beginning. It could have stayed out and it chose not to.
是的，这是一本了不起的书，不是吗？这是一本精彩的书。老实说，这是我读过的关于这个主题的唯一一本书，但读完后，我觉得没必要再读其他的了。我认为这很公平，因为英语中关于这个主题的书并不多。那么让我们从意大利开始吧。我的意思是，正如你所说，意大利在战争初期并没有参加第一次世界大战。它本可以置身事外，但它选择了不这样做。
So why on earth has it made this decision? Yeah, there's a meat grinder. Let's jump into it. Exactly. Italy in 1915 is the sixth most populous state in Europe. It's got 35 million people. So if you think of the big guns, Russia, Austria, Hungary, Britain, France, Germany and so on. Italy is the sixth.
那么，它到底为什么要做出这个决定呢？是的，这是一个绞肉机。让我们深入探讨一下。没错。1915年的意大利是欧洲人口第六大国。它有3500万人口。所以如果你想到那些大国，俄罗斯、奥匈帝国、英国、法国、德国等等。意大利排在第六位。
What Italy has in common with Germany is that it's a new country and you might say if you were being very cynical and our Italian listeners, if there any exist, will at this point turn the podcast off, you might say Italy is an invented country. People have made it up. Well, I think that is harsh. Do you think that's harsh? Yeah. There's some historians who genuinely would argue that. I know, but I mean, the notion of Italy goes back to the Roman period. Of course it does. And so that is something that obviously is lurking in the minds of lots of enthusiasts for a greater Italy, I think. So Italy didn't. exist until the 1850s 1860s. There's a process of unification called the resurgimento,
意大利与德国的共同点在于，它是一个新国家。如果你非常愤世嫉俗的话——如果我们的意大利听众中有人存在的话，此时可能会关掉播客——你可能会说意大利是一个被发明出来的国家。人们编造了它。嗯，我觉得这太苛刻了。你觉得这苛刻吗？是的。有些历史学家确实会这样争论。我知道，但我的意思是，意大利的概念可以追溯到罗马时期。当然是这样。所以这显然潜伏在许多“大意大利”支持者的心中。所以意大利在19世纪50年代、60年代之前并不存在。有一个被称为“复兴运动”的统一进程，
which is led by the kingdom of Piedmont, which was based in Turin, and ruled by the Royal House of Savoy. And basically by force, by diplomacy, by sort of popular nationalist feeling, the House of Savoy managed to weld together a series of territories that by this point are quite distinct. They're sort of economically distinct, they speak very different dialects, and they weld them together to create a new kingdom of Italy. So that what you have in the late 19th century is a process of basically inventing what it is to be an Italian. What do we have in common? What's Italian culture going to be? What dialect are we going to speak and so on and so forth? What national dishes are we going to invent? Right. We did a whole episode on this with Friend of the show John Dickie about the creation of
由总部位于都灵、由萨伏伊王室统治的皮埃蒙特王国领导。基本上，通过武力、外交和某种大众民族主义情绪，萨伏伊王室成功地将一系列在当时已经相当独特的领土焊接在一起。它们在经济上各不相同，说着非常不同的方言，他们将它们焊接在一起，创造了一个新的意大利王国。所以，19世纪末出现的是一个基本上在发明“意大利人”意味着什么的进程。我们有什么共同点？意大利文化将是什么样的？我们将说哪种方言等等？我们将发明哪些民族菜肴？没错。我们和节目好友约翰·迪基做过一期关于通过食物创造
Italian identity through food. Now, one very good way of welding together a new national identity is to have a common enemy and to have a sense of unfinished business, a sense of kind of victimhood or whatever. And in its case, this comes down to its northern frontier. And when nationalists look at the map of the newly unified Italy, they say, it's in the wrong place. So one nationalist says the frontier is a metal wire planted haphazardly where nothing ends or begins, an arbitrary division and amputation alien to nature, law and logic. And Dominic, what sharpens that sense is the fact that on the other side of that border is Austria, the Austrian Empire, and that is the former imperial mistress of Venice and other regions of Italy.
意大利身份的节目。现在，焊接新民族认同的一个非常好的方法是拥有一个共同的敌人，并拥有一种未竟事业的感觉，一种受害者心态等等。就意大利而言，这归结为它的北部边境。当民族主义者看着新统一的意大利地图时，他们说，它在错误的地方。一位民族主义者说，边界是一根随意种植的金属丝，那里没有终点也没有起点，这是一种违背自然、法律和逻辑的武断分割和截肢。多米尼克，加剧这种感觉的是这样一个事实：边界的另一边是奥地利，奥匈帝国，那是威尼斯和意大利其他地区的前帝国女主人。
Exactly. The ancestral enemy, the Austrians. And what also sharpens it is that on the other side of that border, there are some people who speak Italian. So people look at the border and they say, well, what we'd like is I'd like to get the South Tyrell. I mean, there are a lot of German speakers in the South Terrell as well. They say, well, that's never mind.
没错。世仇，奥地利人。加剧这种感觉的还有，在边界的另一边，有一些说意大利语的人。所以人们看着边界说，好吧，我想要南蒂罗尔。我的意思是，南蒂罗尔也有很多讲德语的人。他们说，好吧，没关系。
We can have them in Italy. We'd like the cities of Trieste and Gorizia. Ideally, I think I'd like, we'd like to have Slovenia. And I think a lot of modern Croatia really should be part of Italy. So they want... Maybe Gaul, maybe Italian. They'd say, we'd like the peninsula of Istria. And we would like the coast of Dalmatia.
我们可以把他们纳入意大利。我们想要的里雅斯特和戈里齐亚。理想情况下，我想，我们想要斯洛文尼亚。而且我认为很多现代克罗地亚确实应该成为意大利的一部分。所以他们想要……也许是高卢，也许是意大利。他们会说，我们想要伊斯特拉半岛。我们还想要达尔马提亚海岸。
So there are Italian speakers. all of these areas that belong to the Austro-Hungarian Empire. And the nationalist slogan is unredeemed Italy, Italia Irredenta. And it's from that expression that we get irredentism. So this idea that there's unfinished national business that we need to complete the nation. And this is an idea that's politically very effective in the late 19th century. It allows politicians to appeal across this newly united country to different classes, to workers in their cities, to farmers, to, to,
所以这些属于奥匈帝国的地区都有讲意大利语的人。民族主义者的口号是“未收复的意大利”（Italia Irredenta）。我们从这个表达中得到了“民族统一主义”（irredentism）。所以这种想法是，有未完成的民族事业，我们需要完成国家统一。这是一个在19世纪末政治上非常有效的想法。它允许政治家跨越这个新统一的国家，向不同的阶层呼吁，向城市里的工人、农民、
urban intellectuals, all of this kind of thing. And as you said, there is a parallel in Germany. Exactly. Now, rather like the Germans, the Italians feel they've united a little bit too late. They've been shut out of the scramble for foreign colonies, for example, in Africa. And if they want to be a great power, they need colonies. So they look to North Africa initially. Tom, obviously, this is Tom Horan Bingo.
城市知识分子等等呼吁。正如你所说，德国也有类似的情况。没错。现在，就像德国人一样，意大利人觉得他们统一得有点太晚了。例如，他们被排除在非洲的海外殖民地争夺之外。如果他们想成为大国，他们就需要殖民地。所以他们最初看向北非。汤姆，显然这是“汤姆·霍兰宾果”。
The example of the Roman Empire is hanging over them the whole time. They want to basically rebuild the Roman Empire as much as possible. They look to North Africa, but to their horror, a much bigger power has already got stuck in in North Africa, and that's France. And actually, the French make it pretty obvious. They don't want the Italians getting involved. And there's a bit of a rivalry between the French and the Italians in North Africa. And as a result of that, the Italians sign a very implausible alliance in 1882. First of all, with Germany, that's not so implausible, but Austria, but with Austria as well.
罗马帝国的例子一直悬在他们头上。他们基本上想尽可能地重建罗马帝国。他们看向北非，但令他们惊恐的是，一个更强大的大国已经陷入了北非，那就是法国。事实上，法国人表现得很明显。他们不希望意大利人参与进来。北非的法国人和意大利人之间存在一些竞争。结果，意大利人在1882年签署了一个非常不可思议的联盟。首先是与德国，这并不那么不可思议，但与奥地利也签署了。
That's mad. And this is basically to give them a bit more of a free hand in Africa so that the French won't attack them. And it's called the Triple Alliance. A lot of nationalists are very uneasy about it. What are we getting into bed with the Austrians for? They're our enemies. However, the upside, this allows Italy to pursue some colonial adventures.
这太疯狂了。这基本上是为了让他们在非洲有更多的行动自由，这样法国人就不会攻击他们。这被称为“三国同盟”。许多民族主义者对此感到非常不安。我们为什么要和奥地利人同流合污？他们是我们的敌人。然而，好处是，这允许意大利进行一些殖民冒险。
So in Eritrea, in Somaliland, in Abyssinia, Ethiopia, and most obviously in Libya. And these go generally very badly. I mean, the Italians do make inroads, but their army consistently performs very badly. So in Abyssinia, 6,000 Italian soldiers were massacred in a single day at the Battle of Adwa in 1896. And there's still a sense when you get into the 20th century that nationalist ambitions have not been sated, that Italy still needs to prove its virility on the world stage. Yeah, because in Rome at this point, they're building an enormous monument on the capital, which is the great sacred hill of Rome.
所以在厄立特里亚、索马里兰、阿比西尼亚（埃塞俄比亚），最明显的是在利比亚。这些冒险通常进行得非常糟糕。我的意思是，意大利人确实取得了进展，但他们的军队表现一直很差。例如，在阿比西尼亚，1896年的阿杜瓦战役中，6000名意大利士兵在一天之内被屠杀。进入20世纪，人们仍然觉得民族抱负尚未得到满足，意大利仍然需要在世界舞台上证明自己的阳刚之气。是的，因为此时在罗马，他们正在卡比托利欧山上建造一座巨大的纪念碑，那是罗马神圣的山丘。
And this is a monument to Victor Emmanuel II, who'd been the king when Italy had been united. And there's a sense, I mean, anyone who's been to Rome will immediately be able to picture it. It looks like something out of a Cecil B. de Mill film about ancient Rome. It's kind of symbolically illustrating the fusion between the unity of Italy and this kind of glorious Roman past, which it is assumed a united Italy will be a united Italy will be a unity.
这是为了纪念维克多·伊曼纽尔二世，他是意大利统一时的国王。这种感觉，任何去过罗马的人都会立刻在脑海中浮现出它的样子。它看起来像是塞西尔·B·德米尔拍摄的关于古罗马电影里的东西。它象征性地说明了意大利的统一与这种辉煌的罗马过去之间的融合，人们认为统一的意大利将是……统一的意大利将是……
to resurrect. Exactly. And that's not completed, I think, until 1911. So just before, before the outbreak of the war. It's a monstrosity, actually, isn't it? It's a wedding cake. Yeah. I think, yes, I think absolutely right that the sense of becoming a great power and building a united nation that those two things are interfused. And there's this sort of sense of unfinished business, this sense of pressure and of, um, slight disappointment, almost hanging over the Italian project as you enter the 20th century. Now, at this point, Italy is changing a lot. It's industrialising, it's building railways and schools. It is, however, a long way behind the other so-called great powers.
复兴。没错。而且我认为直到1911年才完工。就在战争爆发前夕。它实际上是个怪物，不是吗？它像个结婚蛋糕。是的，我认为绝对正确的是，成为大国和建立统一国家的意识，这两者是融合在一起的。进入20世纪时，意大利的计划中笼罩着一种未竟事业的感觉，一种压力感，以及一种轻微的失望感。现在，此时的意大利正在发生巨大变化。它正在工业化，正在修建铁路和学校。然而，它远远落后于其他所谓的“大国”。
It's only got a very small urban middle class. The vast majority of Italians work on the land as peasants. Literacy rates are very low. Infant mortality is very high. The state, most people have only have a very vague sense of what the state is. Their horizons abounded by the locality, by the village, by the farm, all of this. And only a tiny fraction of the population gets to, vote. So in 1913, 8 million people out of 35 million people. Politics is a sort of endless, as always
它只有一个非常小的城市中产阶级。绝大多数意大利人作为农民在土地上工作。识字率非常低。婴儿死亡率非常高。对于国家，大多数人对国家是什么只有非常模糊的概念。他们的视野局限于地方、村庄、农场等等。只有极少数人口能够投票。所以1913年，3500万人中只有800万人。政治是一种无休止的，一如既往
in Italy, an endless sort of dance of coalition building. Politicians who are constantly kind of ditching their principles to meet the demands at the moment. And at the top is the king, Victor Emmanuel, the third. So he's the grandson of the monument guy. He is. And he is a very short man. He's very short. He's very insecure. he's a coin collector, so he's like you, Tom, collects coins. He fancies himself as an amateur photographer. That's his passion. He has loads of power under the Italian constitution.
在意大利，一种无休止的联盟建立之舞。政治家们不断地为了满足当下的需求而抛弃原则。最高层是国王维克多·伊曼纽尔三世。他是那个纪念碑主角的孙子。他是。他是一个非常矮小的男人。他非常矮。他非常缺乏安全感。他是个硬币收藏家，所以他像你一样，汤姆，收集硬币。他自认为是业余摄影师。那是他的爱好。根据意大利宪法，他拥有巨大的权力。
So he can call Parliament to dismiss Parliament. He can appoint the ministers. He directs foreign policy. He commands the army. He declares war. But he doesn't like using his power. In fact, he wants politicians to do it for him. And this in the long run will get him into trouble
所以他可以召集议会，解散议会。他可以任命部长。他指导外交政策。他指挥军队。他宣战。但他不喜欢使用他的权力。事实上，他希望政治家们为他代劳。从长远来看，这会让他陷入麻烦，
because he'll basically turn himself into Benito Mussolini's puppet in the 1920s and 1930s. But at this point, let's go to 1914 when the First World War begins. At this point, his prime minister is a man called Antonio Salandra. Salandra is a conservative lawyer from a rich family, land-owning family in Puglia in the south of Italy, but he's backed by the big business elites in the industrial north because he's a conservative. He's a sort of balding man with this absolutely gigantic moustache, exactly as you would, as you would want.
因为他在20世纪20年代和30年代基本上会把自己变成贝尼托·墨索里尼的傀儡。但在这一点上，让我们回到1914年第一次世界大战开始的时候。此时，他的总理是一个叫安东尼奥·萨兰德拉的人。萨兰德拉是一位保守派律师，来自意大利南部普利亚的一个富裕的土地所有者家庭，但他得到了工业化北部大商业精英的支持，因为他是个保守派。他是一个秃顶的男人，留着你所期望的那种绝对巨大的胡子。
Oh, thank God. It's so good to have an enormous moustache back on the rest of history. It is, of course. Haven't had one for a while. He's a very ruthless and devious man, and he is the man who is basically going to act as the head of the conspiracy to drag Italy into the war against the wishes of its people. Now, when Franz Ferdinand was assassinated in the summer of 1914, team. Italy was going through all kinds of internal ructions, massive strikes, unrest, talk of socialist and anarchist revolution and whatnot. So Salandra was distracted.
哦，谢天谢地。很高兴在《历史的余味》中再次看到巨大的胡子。当然是。有一段时间没见到了。他是一个非常无情和狡猾的人，他基本上将担任阴谋集团的头目，违背人民的意愿将意大利拖入战争。现在，当弗朗茨·斐迪南在1914年夏天被暗杀时，汤姆。意大利正在经历各种内部动荡，大规模罢工、骚乱，关于社会主义和无政府主义革命的讨论等等。所以萨兰德拉分心了。
But his foreign minister, who was the Marquis of San Giuliano, who was a Sicilian aristocrat, said to the Austrians, I know we're in this alliance with you, but if you attack Serbia, we will not support you. And the reason we don't want to support you, well, basically the Italians don't want to see Austria expand in the Balkans, become more powerful. I mean, that would be mad. No, they don't. And they say, we might accept you attacking Serbia if you gave us the South Tyrol. And the, the Germans actually said to the Austrians, would you think about it? And the Austrian said, hold on, we're about to enter a war to defend our empire. We're not going to start giving bits away, you know, to our random neighbours.
但他的外交部长，圣朱利亚诺侯爵，一位西西里贵族，对奥地利人说，我知道我们和你们有这个联盟，但如果你们攻击塞尔维亚，我们不会支持你们。我们不想支持你们的原因，嗯，基本上意大利人不想看到奥地利在巴尔干半岛扩张，变得更强大。我的意思是，那太疯狂了。不，他们不想。他们说，如果你们把南蒂罗尔给我们，我们或许可以接受你们攻击塞尔维亚。而德国人实际上对奥地利人说，你们考虑一下吗？奥地利人说，等等，我们即将进入一场保卫帝国的战争。我们不会开始把领土分给我们的随机邻居。
So the First World War starts and Italy declares itself neutral. Now, under the Triple Alliance, they didn't actually have to join the war because the Triple Alliance was meant to be a defensive pact, not an offensive one. But I guess it's kind of against the spirit, if not the letter. It is a bit. I think the Austrians and the Germans are disappointed. They say, well, this is really poor from the Italians.
所以第一次世界大战开始了，意大利宣布中立。根据三国同盟，他们实际上不必参加战争，因为三国同盟本应是防御性条约，而不是进攻性条约。但我猜这有点违背精神，如果不是违背条文的话。确实有一点。我认为奥地利人和德国人很失望。他们说，意大利人的表现真的很差。
On the other hand, it's the Italians. So, you know, you kind of know what you're getting into when you're selling an alliance with them. And the Italian said, well, you took us of granted. You didn't consult us. You've got stuck in. There's also good reasons for Italy to stay out. A public opinion, people don't like the Austrians.
另一方面，他们是意大利人。所以，你知道，当你和他们达成联盟时，你多少知道会发生什么。意大利人说，你们把我们视为理所当然。你们没有咨询我们。你们陷入了困境。意大利置身事外也有充分的理由。公众舆论，人们不喜欢奥地利人。
Also, Italy imports a lot of raw materials, including, this is a terrible indictment of Italian agriculture, including food from Britain and France. So if they entered the war on the side of the central powers, the British and French would probably blockade their ports. And people would starve and that would be a right mess. And they don't fancy that. So, they say, we're going to sit this one out. Fine. Just a week later, the Marks,
此外，意大利进口大量原材料，包括——这是对意大利农业的一个可怕控诉——包括来自英国和法国的粮食。所以如果他们站在同盟国一边参战，英法可能会封锁他们的港口。人们会挨饿，那将是一团糟。他们不喜欢那样。所以，他们说，我们要坐视不管。很好。仅仅一周后，圣朱利亚诺
of San Giuliano sends Salandra a note. And he says, I've been thinking, I think if the Allies look like they're going to win, we should actually switch sides and pile in on their side against Austria. And the Marquis has the excellent line, this may not be heroic, but it is wise and patriotic. And the same day, so the 9th of August, the Marcus of San Giuliano starts to send our informal messages to London. If we were to change sides, would you, yeah, just one day. Meanwhile, they say to the chief military commander General Kordauna, who will talk about in the second half, your plans for war against France, just shift them.
侯爵给萨兰德拉发了一张便条。他说，我一直在想，如果盟军看起来要赢，我们实际上应该倒戈，站在他们一边反对奥地利。侯爵有一句精彩的话：这可能不是英雄行为，但它是明智和爱国的。同一天，也就是8月9日，圣朱利亚诺侯爵开始向伦敦发送非正式信息。如果我们倒戈，你们会……是的，仅仅一天。与此同时，他们对军事总指挥官卡多纳将军说——我们将在下半场讨论他——你们针对法国的战争计划，稍微调整一下。
Yeah, just update them a little bit. So it's war now against Austria. Anyway, a month passes. The Germans, of course, have launched their great attack on France. And they've been turned back at the River Man, the Battle of the Man. And Salandra says to his cronies, we should use this historic cataclysm. to, and I quote, complete and enlarge the fatherland. And he acknowledges, people will say that we've been very sneaky and perfidious.
是的，稍微更新一下。所以现在是对奥地利开战。无论如何，一个月过去了。德国人当然已经对法国发动了大规模进攻。他们在马恩河战役中被击退了。萨兰德拉对他的亲信说，我们应该利用这场历史性的灾难，来，引用他的话，“完成并扩大祖国”。他承认，人们会说我们非常狡猾和背信弃义。
But he says, Italy's destiny should be guided by, and he uses the phrase sacro egoismo, sacred egoism. And this becomes one of the most famous phrases in modern Italian history. And that idea of sacred egoism expresses the, dare I say, the sacral quality of Italian nationalism. sacral, sacral poor behavior. Yes, it is. They believe they have a kind of divinely appointed mission to complete the unification of the nation. And if that involves taking large parts of other people's countries and stabbing them in the back.
但他表示，意大利的命运应该由——他使用了“神圣利己主义”（sacro egoismo）这个词——来引导。这成为了现代意大利历史上最著名的短语之一。而“神圣利己主义”这个概念表达了，我敢说，意大利民族主义的神圣性。神圣的，神圣的恶劣行为。是的，确实如此。他们相信他们有一种神圣任命的使命来完成国家统一。如果这涉及到夺取别人国家的大片领土并在背后捅刀子。
So much the better. Yeah. So there's now a long, complicated diplomatic dance. In January 1915, Salandra sends a message to Vienna. And he says, I'd like you to give us Trento, the Trentino, this sort of area. in the north and South Tyrell. We'd like a bit of Slovenia, please. And we'd like Trieste to be neutral and autonomous.
那就更好了。是的。所以现在有一场漫长而复杂的外交之舞。1915年1月，萨兰德拉给维也纳发了一条信息。他说，我希望你们把特伦托、特伦蒂诺，这个北部地区和南蒂罗尔给我们。我们想要一点斯洛文尼亚，拜托。我们希望的里雅斯特中立且自治。
The Austrians really like Trieste because it's their one big port. They don't want to give that away. And the Austrians say, I'm not going to give you all that. What? You meant you were an ally only recently. We're not going to give you large pits of our empire. Now, Salamtera expects that to happen. And in fact, he doesn't mind because he's already eyeing up, you know, the Adriatic coast.
奥地利人真的很喜欢的里雅斯特，因为那是他们唯一的大港口。他们不想放弃它。奥地利人说，我不会把这一切都给你们。什么？你们不久前还是盟友。我们不会把我们帝国的大片领土给你们。现在，萨兰德拉预料到了会发生这种情况。事实上，他并不介意，因为他已经盯上了亚得里亚海海岸。
Are the Austrians kind of alerted by this? to the possibility that they might jump ship. Yes, they definitely are. They can sort of feel it coming, but they're not going to buy off the Italians by giving them big chunks of their empire. I'm just wondering if they're starting to beef up their defenses. Yeah, they are, but of course, don't forget, in this period of time, this is the point that we talked about in our very first World War series.
奥地利人是否因为这种可能性而警觉起来，认为他们可能会倒戈？是的，他们绝对警觉了。他们能感觉到它要来了，但他们不会通过把帝国的大片领土给意大利人来收买他们。我只是想知道他们是否开始加强防御了。是的，他们是，但当然，别忘了，在这段时间里，这就是我们在第一次世界大战系列节目中讨论的重点。
But the Russians are coming, aren't they? The Russians are coming, and Tom, you will recall that there's the tremendous battle for the city of Prozimus. Of course. How could I forget? Yeah. Where was it? The fortress city of Pugianche.
但俄国人要来了，不是吗？俄国人要来了，汤姆，你会记得普热梅希尔市有一场巨大的战役。当然。我怎么会忘记？是的。在哪里？普热梅希尔要塞城市。
Great to have that back on the show. So late February, 1915, Cilandra's envoys present a secret deal to the Allies in London. They say, we'll enter the war on the Allied side, and in return, here is our shopping list. We'd like the Saar Trentino. We'd like Trieste and Garizia. We'd like Istria, now Croatia. We'd like Dalmatia, so that's the coast of Croatia and the islands. We'd like a little bit of Albania.
很高兴再次在节目中提到它。所以1915年2月底，萨兰德拉的特使向伦敦的盟军提出了一个秘密交易。他们说，我们将站在盟军一边参战，作为回报，这是我们的购物清单。我们想要南特伦蒂诺。我们想要的里雅斯特和戈里齐亚。我们想要伊斯特拉，现在的克罗地亚。我们想要达尔马提亚，也就是克罗地亚海岸和岛屿。我们想要一点阿尔巴尼亚。
We'd ideally like the Dodecanese islands of roads, costs, patmos and so on. And we'd like £50 million to pay for the war. Now, the Germans have got wind of this. They persuade the Austrians to make a generous counter-offer. At this point, the Austrians are actually saying to them, OK, we'll give you South Tyrol, we'll give you a bit of Western Slovenia, we will make Trieste Autonomous, we can even let you have a little bit of Albania. At this point, the Italians are feeling very greedy,
我们理想中想要罗得岛、科斯岛、帕特莫斯岛等十二群岛。我们还想要5000万英镑来支付战争费用。现在，德国人听到了风声。他们说服奥地利人做出慷慨的反提议。此时，奥地利人实际上在对他们说，好吧，我们会给你们南蒂罗尔，我们会给你们一点西斯洛文尼亚，我们会让的里雅斯特自治，我们甚至可以让你们拥有一点阿尔巴尼亚。此时，意大利人感到非常贪婪，
and they don't want to accept the Austrian offer. and they say to the Allies, we'd really like to get into bed with you, please. If you give us all this, we'll enter the war. And this whole kind of getting into bed with people for money, how does this go down with people in London and Paris? Well, I'm sorry to say, Tom, that it reinforces existing stereotypes of Italian behaviour among the policy makers of London and Paris.
他们不想接受奥地利的提议。他们对盟军说，我们真的很想和你们结盟，拜托。如果你们给我们这一切，我们就参战。而这种为了钱和人“上床”的行为，在伦敦和巴黎的人看来怎么样？嗯，我很遗憾地说，汤姆，它强化了伦敦和巴黎决策者对意大利行为的既有刻板印象。
So when they look at the map, they say, what, you want Dalmatia? There are 18,000 Italian speakers in Dalmatia. but half a million Slavs. It seems unreasonable for you to ask for this. How can this be justified? Winston Churchill said that Italy was the harlot of Europe. So Herbert Henry Asquith, the British Prime Minister, of course, a man of the most impeccable moral, sexual behaviour.
所以当他们看地图时，他们说，什么，你们想要达尔马提亚？达尔马提亚有18000名意大利语使用者，但有50万斯拉夫人。你们要求这个似乎不合理。这怎么能被证明是正当的？温斯顿·丘吉尔说意大利是“欧洲的妓女”。所以赫伯特·亨利·阿斯奎斯，英国首相，当然，一个道德和性行为无可挑剔的人。
Yeah, very much a friend of the show. He described Italy as voracious, slippery and perfidious. He said, right, the excellent line. It is so important to bring Italy in at once, as greedy and slippery as she is, that we ought not to be too precise in haggling over this or that. Now, of course, this would create great problems in the future when the Italians feel they've been cheated. Because at this point, basically, the Allies say, fine, you can have everything you want. Yeah, we'll give you everything.
是的，非常是节目的朋友。他形容意大利是“贪婪、滑头和背信弃义的”。他说，对，那句精彩的话。立即让意大利加入是如此重要，尽管她贪婪且滑头，但我们不应该在讨价还价上过于精确。现在，当然，这将在未来造成巨大的问题，当意大利人觉得他们被欺骗时。因为在这一点上，基本上，盟军说，好吧，你们可以得到你们想要的一切。是的，我们会给你们一切。
You can have loads of Croatia, you can have loads of Slovenia. You can actually rule a million Germans and Slavs, if you like, if you really want to do that badly. And actually, do you know what, if the Ottoman Empire falls apart, You can have that as well. You can have a bit of Turkey as well. Go for it. I think it's fair to say they don't really mean it. They're just promising anything.
你们可以拥有大量的克罗地亚，你们可以拥有大量的斯洛文尼亚。如果你们真的想那样做，你们甚至可以统治一百万德国人和斯拉夫人。事实上，你知道吗，如果奥斯曼帝国分崩离析，你们也可以拥有它。你们也可以拥有土耳其的一小部分。去吧。我认为公平地说，他们并不是真的当真。他们只是在承诺任何事情。
And so Italy formally repudiates the Triple Alliance. So now we're in May. And the stage ought to be set for war, but there is a problem. First of all, Victor Emmanuel III, with his coins and his very short stature and whatnot, he does not really want the war. He doesn't like the idea of war at all. more importantly, the Italian people don't really want a war. So Slandre asks his regional governors, what do ordinary people think?
于是意大利正式否认了三国同盟。现在是5月了。舞台本应为战争做好准备，但有一个问题。首先，维克多·伊曼纽尔三世，带着他的硬币和他非常矮的身材等等，他并不真正想要战争。他根本不喜欢战争的想法。更重要的是，意大利人民并不真正想要战争。所以萨兰德拉问他的地区长官，普通人怎么想？
And the governors come back and they say, actually most people say they don't want to fight. They've had a look at the First World War and they think it's possibly not brilliant. It's probably best to sit this one out. All that gas and rats and mud and stuff. Right. And in the south, in the poorer part of the country, people are really against it. So the governor of Naples says 90% of people in the city, including all the social, classes, hate the thought of war. And basically, across the board, the people who want war are
长官们回来后说，实际上大多数人说他们不想打仗。他们看了看第一次世界大战，认为这可能不是什么好主意。最好还是置身事外。那些毒气、老鼠和泥浆之类的东西。没错。在南部，在国家较贫穷的地区，人们非常反对它。所以那不勒斯的长官说，城里90%的人，包括所有社会阶层，都讨厌战争的想法。基本上，全面来看，想要战争的人是
intellectuals, poets, bad people, Tom. If there are nothing they don't know. How on earth is the Italian government going to rouse the nation for war? And the answer is by enlisting the most celebrated and colourful and controversial Italian of his generation. And this is this bloke we began with Gabrielle Donuncio. So Danuncio, we did a whole episode on him back in 2022, called The First Fascist with his biographer Lucy Hughes Hallett. Oh, yeah. The Pike. Brilliant book.
知识分子、诗人、坏人，汤姆。如果他们一无所知。意大利政府到底要如何唤起全国进行战争？答案是招募他那一代最著名、最丰富多彩、最具争议的意大利人。这就是我们开头提到的加布里埃尔·邓南遮。所以邓南遮，我们在2022年做过一整期关于他的节目，题为《第一个法西斯分子》，嘉宾是他的传记作者露西·休斯-哈利特。哦，是的。那本书。精彩的书。
Yes. Now, Danuncio, for those people who haven't heard that episode, was the most famous Italian in the world at this point. He's a playwright and a poet. He's a dandy. He's a decadent. He's always in the gossip columns. He's a proper celebrity.
是的。现在，邓南遮，对于那些没听过那期节目的人来说，是当时世界上最著名的意大利人。他是一位剧作家和诗人。他是个花花公子。他是个颓废派。他总是在八卦专栏里。他是个真正的名人。
I mean, we've been talking about moustaches. Yeah. He has a brilliant moustache, but it's not a kind of military moustache, is it? It's a kind of the excitement of the new, faintly fascist, flamboyant, let's fly on a plane kind of a mustache. Exactly. The weird thing about him is, everyone says he's this sort of tremendous, he's always in and out of aristocratic women's bedrooms and stuff. He's a very short man. He's got no hair at all.
我的意思是，我们一直在谈论胡子。是的。他有一撇精彩的胡子，但那不是一种军事胡子，对吧？那是一种对新事物的兴奋，带有轻微的法西斯色彩，华丽，让我们坐飞机的那种胡子。没错。关于他奇怪的是，每个人都说他是那种了不起的，他总是进出贵族妇女的卧室之类的。他是个非常矮的男人。他根本没有头发。
He's extremely ugly. People always comment on how terrible his teeth are. And he's so narcissistic and egotistical that he's practically sociopathic. It gives us all hope. His life is strewn with wreckage. So basically bad debts, broken homes, abandoned children. He's just a terrible, terrible person. But because he writes, I mean, the stuff when you actually read it, it's dated really badly.
他极其丑陋。人们总是评论他的牙齿有多糟糕。而且他如此自恋和自负，以至于几乎是反社会人格。这给了我们所有人希望。他的一生充满了残骸。基本上是坏账、破碎的家庭、被遗弃的孩子。他只是一个非常非常糟糕的人。但因为他写作，我的意思是，当你真正读到那些东西时，它已经过时得很厉害了。
It's so lush and ornate and stuff. But he's very highly rated, isn't he? I mean, Joyce thinks he's great. Proust thinks he's great. I mean, they love him. People think he's a genius. People think he's one of the authentic literary geniuses of the early 20th century. He's got off to Paris to escape his creditors, but people adore him and women in particular can't get enough of him.
它太华丽、太繁琐了。但他评价很高，不是吗？我的意思是，乔伊斯认为他很棒。普鲁斯特认为他很棒。我的意思是，他们爱他。人们认为他是天才。人们认为他是20世纪初真正的文学天才之一。他去巴黎逃避债主，但人们崇拜他，尤其是女性对他爱不释手。
Now, Donuncio is an ultra-nationalist. Donuncio has been writing about glory, national and personal, since he was a little boy. Ever since the 1880s, he's been pouring out newspaper articles, wittering on about the army and the Navy. And the Air Force, isn't it? Because he's very, very keen on planes. He never learns to fly, but he's obsessed by air power. He is. He's very much of that kind of futurist mentality where everything is about new technology and the excitement of war and all of this. Although he is quite keen on kind of ancient dreams of empire as well, isn't he?
现在，邓南遮是一个极端民族主义者。邓南遮从小就一直在写关于国家和个人荣耀的文章。自19世纪80年代以来，他一直在发表报纸文章，喋喋不休地谈论陆军和海军。还有空军，不是吗？因为他非常、非常热衷于飞机。他从没学会飞行，但他痴迷于空中力量。他是。他非常具有那种未来主义心态，一切都与新技术、战争的兴奋感有关。尽管他也非常热衷于那种古老的帝国梦想，不是吗？
He is. It's the sort of fusion of the two. Yeah. So that's how he's the proto-fascist. Quite fascistic. He was very keen on conquering Libya in 1911. He's been talking for ages. Let's have an empire in the Balkans. He was very keen on joining the First World War. And he actually said, I won't come home until we join the war. But I fear that the Italian political class are too weak, and we never will. And then, in March 1915, he opens a letter in Paris that has been lying around for weeks since laying unopened. And it's an invitation to come and speak at an event in May, just outside Genoa. This is the place from which Garibaldi and his volunteers had sailed to Sicily in 1860.
他是。这是两者的融合。是的。所以这就是他为什么是原始法西斯分子。相当法西斯。他非常热衷于1911年征服利比亚。他已经谈论了很久。让我们在巴尔干半岛建立一个帝国吧。他非常热衷于加入第一次世界大战。他甚至说，除非我们加入战争，否则我不会回家。但我担心意大利政治阶层太软弱，我们永远不会加入。然后，在1915年3月，他在巴黎打开了一封信，这封信已经在那里放了几个星期没拆封。这是一份邀请，邀请他参加5月在热那亚郊外举行的一次活动。这就是加里波第和他的志愿者们在1860年航行前往西西里岛的地方。
And they're going to inaugurate a monument, and they want Donencio to come and give a talk. And he thinks, well, this is it. This is a brilliant opportunity to come and preach my warlike message to the Italian people. So he gets on a train in Paris on the 3rd of May, 1915. He crosses the Italian border for the first time in five years. He is met by colossal crowds. He's a sort of Lucy Hughes-Hallerton, a book calls him a nationalist messiah. It's like the prophet returning to his people.
他们要为一个纪念碑揭幕，他们想让邓南遮来发表演讲。他想，好吧，就是这个了。这是一个向意大利人民宣扬我好战信息的绝佳机会。所以他在1915年5月3日登上了去巴黎的火车。他五年来第一次跨越意大利边境。他受到了巨大人群的欢迎。露西·休斯-哈利特的书称他为“民族主义弥赛亚”。就像先知回到了他的人民身边。
Massive crowds of sort of poets and intellectuals cheering excitedly. Your vibe. It's like when we arrive at a to do a rest of his history. tour, surely. There's the... He gets to Genoa, massive crowds, and he gives the first, there'll be a lot of blood-curdling speeches. He gives the first of the series of mad speeches.
成群结队的诗人和知识分子兴奋地欢呼。你的氛围。这就像我们到达《历史的余味》巡演时一样，肯定。他到达热那亚，人群拥挤，他发表了第一次，会有很多令人毛骨悚然的演讲。他发表了这一系列疯狂演讲中的第一次。
We shall not let Italy be dishonoured, we shall not let the fatherland perish. We shall have a greater Italy, not by acquisition, but by conquest, not measured in shame, but as the price of blood and glory. I mean, nobody ever talks more enthusiastically about blood and glory than this bloke.
我们绝不能让意大利蒙羞，我们绝不能让祖国灭亡。我们将拥有一个更伟大的意大利，不是通过获取，而是通过征服，不是以羞耻来衡量，而是作为鲜血和荣耀的代价。我的意思是，没有人比这家伙更热情地谈论鲜血和荣耀了。
Next day, he goes to the monument to do the unveiling to give the speech. And the speech is meant to be all about Garibaldi. And actually, it's just all about war and how brilliant war is. He ends with this peroration that even though I've, you know, read it many times and written about it in my kids book about the First World War, I still actually find shocking every time I look at it. Because it's a parody of the sermon on the mount in favor of fighting and killing.
第二天，他去纪念碑揭幕并发表讲话。演讲本应是关于加里波第的。实际上，它全是关于战争以及战争有多么辉煌。他以这段演讲结束，即使我已经（你知道）读过很多次，并在我关于第一次世界大战的儿童书中写过它，但我每次看它时仍然感到震惊。因为它是对“登山宝训”的模仿，支持战斗和杀戮。
Blessed are the 20-year-olds, pure of mind, well-tempered in body with courageous mothers. blessed are the young who hunger and thirst for glory, for they should be satisfied. Blessed are the merciful, for they shall wipe away a splendid flow of blood and bind up their shining wounds. Blessed are they who return with victories, for they shall see the new face of Rome. And all this. And people complain, don't they? And he kind of basically says, you know, if it's wrong to incite people to violence,
“祝福那些20岁的年轻人，思想纯洁，身体强健，有勇敢的母亲。祝福那些渴望荣耀的年轻人，因为他们将得到满足。祝福那些仁慈的人，因为他们将擦去灿烂的血流，包扎他们闪亮的伤口。祝福那些带着胜利归来的人，因为他们将看到罗马的新面孔。”所有这些。人们抱怨，不是吗？他基本上说，你知道，如果煽动人们暴力是错误的，
then so be it. Yeah. I plead guilty. Brilliant. Let's have more of it. Exactly, he does. And one of the men in his audience that day is a young journalist with a very dark future. And this is a young man 33 years old called Benito Mussolini. And Mussolini had been an editor of the socialist newspaper, Avanti. He is absolutely typical of this intellectual class. He's read Marx and Engels Mussolini. He's a big fan of Italian futurist poetry. Like Danuncio, who's obsessed with Nietzsche, the sort of Darwinian idea of struggle. Will to power. The will to power. Hates George Eliot. Does Mussolini hate George Eliot?
那就这样吧。是的。我认罪。太棒了。让我们多来点这种事。没错，他确实这么做了。那天在他听众席中的一个人是一位有着非常黑暗未来的年轻记者。这就是一位33岁的年轻人，名叫贝尼托·墨索里尼。墨索里尼曾是社会主义报纸《前进报》的编辑。他完全是这种知识分子阶层的典型。他读过马克思和恩格斯。他是意大利未来主义诗歌的忠实粉丝。像邓南遮一样，他痴迷于尼采，痴迷于那种达尔文式的斗争思想。权力意志。权力意志。他讨厌乔治·艾略特。墨索里尼讨厌乔治·艾略特吗？
Yeah, despises her. Wow, why? Doesn't like Middlemarch? He thinks that she's very ostentatiously given up Christianity, but she's still completely Christian. And she's an idiot because she hasn't realized that's a problem. He's always going on about it. Criky.
是的，鄙视她。哇，为什么？不喜欢《米德尔马契》？他认为她非常炫耀地放弃了基督教，但她骨子里还是个彻头彻尾的基督徒。而且她是个白痴，因为她没意识到那是个问题。他总是喋喋不休地谈论这个。天哪。
Well, Mussolini had always been a non-interventionist. He'd been opposed to Italy's adventures in Africa. He'd said he didn't want to join the First World War. but then in October 1914 he sort of sensed the way the wind was blowing and he decided to completely change his mind I mean I guess that's the mark of a good journalist right I suppose yes I suppose that's one way of looking at it but I didn't think we'd be into rehabilitating Mussolini well I'm not his journalistic acumen I mean newspapers have been known to kind of jump on bandwagons before they have indeed so he found a new newspaper and he sets up his own political movement Mussolini arguing for war with some French and British allied funding by the And he calls it the leagues of revolutionary action, the fasci d'adzionari, Fashchi, meaning the kind of bans or leagues, and it's from that, of course, that we get the word
嗯，墨索里尼一直是个不干涉主义者。他曾反对意大利在非洲的冒险行动。他说过他不想参加第一次世界大战。但后来在1914年10月，他似乎察觉到了风向，于是决定彻底改变主意。我的意思是，我想这就是一个好记者的标志，对吧？我想是的，我想这是一种看待方式，但我没想到我们会去为墨索里尼平反。嗯，我不是在说他的新闻敏锐度，我的意思是报纸以前也曾有过随波逐流的先例。确实如此，所以他创办了一份新报纸，并建立了自己的政治运动，墨索里尼主张参战，并获得了一些英法盟友的资助。他称之为革命行动联盟，即“Fasci d'azione”，Fasci的意思是某种束带或联盟，当然，我们就是从这里得到了这个词
fascism. Anyway, at this point, Mussolini is just in the crowd. The star is Dununcio. Dinocio gives these impassioned speeches to vast crowds. He gets a train to Rome. He arrives in Rome. 100,000 people are waiting, massive crush, massive crowds, gives us. these speeches again. Now, he's starting to denounce what he sees as the traitors, the odor of
法西斯主义。总之，在这一点上，墨索里尼只是人群中的一员。明星是邓南遮。邓南遮向广大群众发表了这些充满激情的演讲。他乘火车前往罗马。他抵达罗马时，有10万人正在等待，场面极其拥挤，人群浩大，他又发表了这些演讲。现在，他开始谴责他所认为的叛徒，那种
treachery that is beginning to stifle us. And by the traitors, he means the politicians who might actually block the attempt to get into war, because right now, politics in Rome is very delicately poised. Because the same day he arrives, the 12th of May, the Italian Parliament opens for a new session. And the stakes are very high. Salandra has done this deal with the allies, but he doesn't have a majority. And Rome is awashed with rumours. that he will fall from power and he will be replaced by the liberal leader who is a man called Giovanni Giulitti.
开始窒息我们的背叛气息。所谓的叛徒，他指的是那些可能真的会阻挠参战企图的政客，因为目前，罗马的政治局势非常微妙。因为在他抵达的同一天，即5月12日，意大利议会开启了新一届会议。赌注非常高。萨兰德拉已经与盟国达成了协议，但他没有获得多数支持。罗马到处都在传言他将下台，并将被自由派领袖乔瓦尼·乔利蒂取代。
Geolitti has been Prime Minister four times already and he does not want to enter the war. So he's not a Danunziot fan. He's not a denunciate fan. I think it would have been a lot better if Giuliety had become Prime Minister and Italy hadn't entered the war. Anyway, the next day, the 13th,
乔利蒂已经四次担任总理，他不想参战。所以他不是邓南遮的粉丝。他不是邓南遮的粉丝。我认为如果乔利蒂成为总理而意大利没有参战，情况会好得多。总之，第二天，即13日，
Salandra pulls off a great political coup, a great bit of political theatre. He unexpectedly resigns, along with his whole cabinet. And he's basically daring the king to appoint Geoliti as Prime Minister and Geoliti to accept the job. And he's betting that they will be put off by the mood on the streets. These huge crowds are pouring through the streets of Rome shouting death to Geolity, up with the war, all this thing. And Tenuncio is going around the city, giving these bonkers speeches.
萨兰德拉上演了一场伟大的政治政变，一场伟大的政治戏码。他出人意料地与整个内阁一起辞职。他基本上是在挑战国王，让国王任命乔利蒂为总理，并让乔利蒂接受这份工作。他打赌他们会被街头的气氛所吓倒。这些巨大的人群涌过罗马街头，高喊着“乔利蒂去死，支持战争”，诸如此类。而邓南遮在城里到处发表这些疯狂的演讲。
The treachery is blatant. We don't only breathe in its horrid stench. We feel it's appalling weight. I tell you there is treason here in Rome. and we're being sold like a herd of diseased cattle. And Tenuncio, again a prefiguring of fascism. He says to the crowds, form squads, lion wait, seize them, by which he means Geolitti and the anti-war politicians.
背叛是明目张胆的。我们不仅呼吸着它那可怕的恶臭。我们还感受到了它那令人震惊的重量。我告诉你们，罗马这里有叛国行为。我们正像一群患病的牛一样被出卖。而邓南遮，再次预示了法西斯主义。他对人群说，组建小队，狮子等待，抓住他们，他指的是乔利蒂和反战政客。
Capture them and all this. Didn't Mussolini call him the John the Baptist of fascism? Yes, he did. Yeah. Well, he absolutely is the John the Baptist of Fascism. If Tenuncio had been left to his own devices, he would have been the John the Baptist and the Jesus of fascism. But he is outsmarted by Mussolini.
抓住他们，诸如此类。墨索里尼不是称他为法西斯主义的施洗约翰吗？是的，他确实这么说过。嗯，他绝对是法西斯主义的施洗约翰。如果邓南遮听之任之，他本会成为法西斯主义的施洗约翰和耶稣。但他被墨索里尼算计了。
He goes on to set up his kind of mad regime in Fume, doesn't he, after the war? He does, which is a massive prefiguring of Mussolini, actually, where he calls himself the duché. So anyway, he's giving these crazy speeches. Blood will flow, but blood will be blessed, all this kind of thing. And the crowds are getting more and more impassioned. Gileiti, the anti-war politician, goes to see the king, and he says, I can't take office against this backdrop.
战后他继续在阜姆建立了那种疯狂的政权，不是吗？他确实这么做了，这实际上是对墨索里尼的巨大预演，他自称为“领袖”（Duce）。总之，他发表了这些疯狂的演讲。鲜血会流淌，但鲜血将是神圣的，诸如此类。人群变得越来越激动。反战政客乔利蒂去见国王，他说，在这种背景下我无法就职。
There'll be a nationalist rebellion. There could be civil war. I don't want to do it. And so on the 16th, the king reinstates Salandra as prime minister, and the king says to Parliament, I think you're just going to have to vote for the war. And I'll abdicate if you don't, because the king has lost his nerve himself.
会发生民族主义叛乱。可能会有内战。我不想这么做。于是16日，国王恢复了萨兰德拉的总理职务，国王对议会说，我想你们只能投票支持战争。如果你们不投，我就退位，因为国王自己也失去了勇气。
As another nationalist journalist puts it in his newspaper, either Parliament will prostitute the sacred, trembling body of the nation to the foreigner. I mean, that rhetoric is so kind of 1910s. Or the nation will overthrow Parliament, overturning the benches of the money lenders, purifying the dens of the pimps and panders with iron and fire. I mean, it is amazing the kind of the twisting of language from the New Testament to promote war. Yeah, I know, I know. It's extraordinary, isn't it? I mean, of all these deranged speeches, probably, I mean, I think this is one of the worst.
正如另一位民族主义记者在他的报纸上所写的那样，要么议会将把国家神圣、颤抖的身体出卖给外国人。我的意思是，这种修辞太像1910年代的风格了。要么国家将推翻议会，推翻放债人的长椅，用铁与火净化皮条客和拉皮条者的巢穴。我的意思是，这种从《新约》中扭曲语言来煽动战争的方式真是令人惊叹。是的，我知道，我知道。这太不寻常了，不是吗？我的意思是，在所有这些精神错乱的演讲中，可能，我认为这是最糟糕的一次。
This is Danuncio. He goes to the Capitoline Hill, where, as you said, they've been building that giant, kind of wedding cake, this sort of symbol of Italian nationalism. And he whips his crowd, this giant crowd into a frenzy. He says, the old order must be totally destroyed. We must cast aside the politicians like rotten meat. Sweep away all the filth, into the sewer with all that is vile. He says, Italy will be reborn in fire.
这就是邓南遮。他去了卡比托利欧山，正如你所说，他们一直在那里建造那个巨大的、像结婚蛋糕一样的建筑，这种意大利民族主义的象征。他煽动他的人群，这群巨大的人群陷入了狂热。他说，旧秩序必须被彻底摧毁。我们必须像扔掉腐肉一样抛弃政客。扫除所有的污秽，把所有卑劣的东西都扔进下水道。他说，意大利将在火中重生。
He says again and again, he calls it a Holocaust. It's one of Domencio's favorite words. He says, let's drive out the anti-war politicians. Yeah, they're not just wrong. They are sick. They are diseased. We should drive them out of politics forever. Make lists.
他一遍又一遍地说，他称之为大屠杀。这是邓南遮最喜欢的词之一。他说，让我们赶走反战政客。是的，他们不仅是错了。他们是有病的。他们是病态的。我们应该永远把他们赶出政治舞台。列出名单。
Prescribe them. Be pitiless. Like Sulla or the second triumvirate. Right. Then at the end, I mean, this is also, it feels very Roman. He takes out a sword that had belonged to an agaribald, his lieutenants. And he says, Italy will be born again in blood. I take the sword and draw it.
处决他们。要冷酷无情。就像苏拉或后三头同盟那样。没错。然后在最后，我的意思是，这也感觉非常罗马。他拿出一把属于加里波第的副官的剑。他说，意大利将在鲜血中重生。我拿起剑，拔出它。
I press my lips to the naked blade. I abandon my soul to delirium. Now, that is what you call a far-right speech. That is a far-right speech, exactly. The crowd goes berserk, they kind of rampage through the streets of Rome. Hundreds of people are arrested, but obviously the politicians are never going to stand up to this kind of pressure. And on the 20th of May, Italy's parliament votes for war. So the cliche of 1914 is that the crowds in London and Berlin and whatever are terribly enthusiastic.
我用嘴唇亲吻裸露的刀刃。我将灵魂交给狂乱。现在，这就是你所说的极右翼演讲。那确实是极右翼演讲，没错。人群陷入疯狂，他们在罗马街头横冲直撞。数百人被捕，但显然政客们永远不会在这种压力下屈服。5月20日，意大利议会投票支持战争。所以1914年的陈词滥调是，伦敦、柏林等地的群众都非常狂热。
and baying for blood. Yeah. Which, as we saw in the, you know, when we covered this was a myth. It's ironic that Rome seems to be the one capital where there is incredible enthusiasm. And this is the one capital that actually had the chance of staying out of the war. It is ironic. I suppose it's a little bit misleading. The people in the streets in Rome that day, I don't know if there's research being done,
并渴望鲜血。是的。正如我们所看到的，当我们报道这一点时，这只是一个神话。具有讽刺意味的是，罗马似乎是唯一一个充满不可思议热情的首都。而这恰恰是唯一一个有机会置身事外的首都。这确实很讽刺。我想这有点误导。那天在罗马街头的人，我不知道是否有人做过研究，
how you would even do it on their social background or whatever. I would guess a lot of these people as young are students. they're excited. It's a day out. I think everything we know of Italians who went to the front is that they didn't know what they were fighting for. They were completely baffled and they didn't like it. But they were kind of grudgingly went along because they thought they were fighting in defence of their native country, the classic thing. Right. I'm not disputing that. I mean, that's clearly the case that the vast majority of people in Italy don't want it. But it is amazing that the kind of the stereotype of how the First World War breaks out, which is not true, capitals full of bay, is true in Rome.
你甚至会如何研究他们的社会背景之类的。我猜这些人中很多是年轻人，是学生。他们很兴奋。这只是出去玩的一天。我认为我们所知道的去前线的意大利人，他们不知道自己在为什么而战。他们完全感到困惑，而且他们不喜欢这样。但他们还是勉强同意了，因为他们认为自己在保卫祖国，这是经典的情况。没错。我并不否认这一点。我的意思是，很明显，意大利绝大多数人并不想要战争。但令人惊奇的是，关于第一次世界大战如何爆发的刻板印象，虽然不是真的，即首都充满了狂热，但在罗马却是真的。
Yeah, it is. I mean, I wouldn't have fancied being one of the, I mean, it would be extraordinary to see it, I suppose. This sort of impassioned, feverish, delirious atmosphere. Really, really extraordinary. And as you say, there isn't really anything quite like it in any of the other European capitals when the war breaks out. So as I said, on the 20th of May, Italy's parliament votes for war. And that evening, Donencio gives yet another insane speech. The honor of the fatherland, he says, is saved. Our troops will march on the river Isonzo, which is in Slovenia, and we will turn it red with barbarian blood.
是的，确实如此。我的意思是，我可不想成为其中之一，我的意思是，看到它会很非凡，我想。这种充满激情、狂热、疯狂的气氛。真的，真的非常非凡。正如你所说，当战争爆发时，在其他任何欧洲首都都没有类似的情况。所以正如我所说，5月20日，意大利议会投票支持战争。那天晚上，邓南遮又发表了一次疯狂的演讲。他说，祖国的荣誉得到了拯救。我们的军队将向伊松佐河进军，那是在斯洛文尼亚，我们将用野蛮人的鲜血把它染红。
And two days later, at the railway station in Rome, the triumphant Prime Minister Salandra publicly embraces his Supreme Military Commander General Kodona before Kodona gets on his train to the cheers of the crowds to head north to the war. And it's a beautiful day. The people are crying. They're so excited. They're crying with joy. And there'll be plenty more crying to come. And just as Danunzio had predicted, the river Isonzo will indeed run red with blood. But whose blood, Dominic? But whose blood? Exactly. Because if Salandra and Danencio think this is going to be a triumphant story of Italian glory and Italian victory, they are in for a heck of a shock. Well, we will find out just how big a shock after a break.
两天后，在罗马火车站，凯旋的总理萨兰德拉在最高军事指挥官卡多纳将军登上火车前往北方参战之前，在人群的欢呼声中公开拥抱了他。那是一个美好的日子。人们在哭泣。他们太兴奋了。他们喜极而泣。未来还会有更多的哭泣。正如邓南遮所预言的那样，伊松佐河确实会血流成河。但那是谁的血呢，多米尼克？但那是谁的血？没错。因为如果萨兰德拉和邓南遮认为这将是一个关于意大利荣耀和意大利胜利的凯旋故事，那他们可要大吃一惊了。好吧，休息之后我们将找出到底会有多大的震惊。
This episode is brought to you by the Times and by the Sunday Times. Now, if there is one thing that history, and indeed Bob Dylan, teaches us, it is that the times they are always are changing. And Dominic, I guess we're living in changing times now, what with America attacking Iran and oil crises. So do you think that the lessons of that for Kirstama are rosy? So looking at the career of Edward Heath, for instance, who was Prime Minister in the previous oil crisis.
本集由《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》赞助播出。现在，如果说历史，以及鲍勃·迪伦，教会了我们什么，那就是时代总是在变。多米尼克，我想我们现在正生活在变化的时代，美国袭击伊朗和石油危机。所以你认为这对基尔·斯塔默来说是乐观的吗？比如看看爱德华·希思的职业生涯，他在上一次石油危机中担任总理。
It didn't work out brilliantly for Ted Heath, to be honest. Actually, he and Kirstarmer, I think, are quite similar. They're from relatively humble backgrounds, and there's a slight sense of floundering, which they have in common. But their bigger point is you never really know what's around the corner, do you? Because when you look at history, the future is always pretty uncertain. But, you know, the facts, they shouldn't be uncertain. And that, of course, is where the Times and the Sunday Times come in.
老实说，这对泰德·希思来说结果并不好。实际上，我认为他和基尔·斯塔默非常相似。他们都出身相对卑微，而且有一种共同的挣扎感。但他们更重要的观点是，你永远不知道转角处会发生什么，对吧？因为当你审视历史时，未来总是相当不确定的。但是，你知道，事实，它们不应该是不可确定的。当然，这就是《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》发挥作用的地方。
Yeah, and I would say that understanding the news is absolutely vital when you're navigating an increasingly uncertain and unpredictable world. So to subscribe to the Times and the Sunday Times, visit thetimes.com. Hello, everyone, and welcome back to the rest of history. It is the 23rd of May, 1915, and in... Vienna, Italy's ambassador has turned up to tell the Austrian government that from midnight, a state of war will exist between their two countries. The ambassador does this with no enthusiasm whatsoever.
是的，我会说，当你在一个日益不确定和不可预测的世界中航行时，理解新闻是绝对至关重要的。因此，要订阅《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》，请访问thetimes.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。现在是1915年5月23日，在维也纳，意大利大使已经出现，告诉奥地利政府，从午夜开始，两国之间将进入战争状态。大使做这件事时毫无热情可言。
In fact, he's absolutely appalled, isn't he? He privately thinks that the Italians have been, and I quote, swinish and faithless, but he's an ambassador, so he has to do his master's bidding. Yeah. And meanwhile, you mentioned General Cardona, General Luigi Cardona. He's headed off from Rome, and he has arrived at what are going to be his headquarters in the palace of the Archbishop in Odine, in northern Italy. He's not going to be a ringing success, is he, in the forthcoming campaign.
事实上，他感到非常震惊，不是吗？他私下认为意大利人一直，我引用一下，“像猪一样且背信弃义”，但他是一位大使，所以他必须听从主人的命令。是的。与此同时，你提到了卡多纳将军，路易吉·卡多纳将军。他已经从罗马出发，抵达了位于意大利北部乌迪内大主教宫殿的总部。他在即将到来的战役中不会取得巨大的成功，对吧？
It's a spoiler. I mean, again, we've been talking about these stereotypes that we have of the First World War and how kind of terrible the generals on both sides are on the Western Front. And we were talking in the previous episode, that's not entirely fair. Kodona, I mean, he kind of is the stereotype of a hopeless general who just keeps hurling his troops forwards and forwards and forwards, no matter how often they get gunned down. Dead right. You're dead right. He ticks every box. He's got an absolutely colossal mustache. Oh, do you think? I looked at him. I thought it was not quite as big as it could be. Really? Yeah. I was disappointed.
这是一个剧透。我的意思是，我们一直在谈论我们对第一次世界大战的刻板印象，以及双方的将军在西线是多么糟糕。我们在上一集中谈到，这并不完全公平。卡多纳，我的意思是，他确实是那种绝望将军的刻板印象，无论他的部队被击毙多少次，他都只是不断地把他们向前推进。你说得对。你说得完全对。他符合所有条件。他留着极其巨大的胡子。哦，你觉得吗？我看了他一眼。我觉得它没有想象中那么大。真的吗？是的。我很失望。
I think it's because you've been brutalized and desensitized by the Russians' moustaches. Yeah. Of like Paul von, what's it, General von Renncamp's mustache or whatever. These colossal moustaches. And I think actually if you were to see Codornas mustache in the wild, as it were. Yeah, probably. If a go-hanger producer turned out with that moustache. Oh, for sure.
我想这是因为你被俄罗斯人的胡子给摧残和麻木了。是的。比如保罗·冯·伦坎普将军的胡子之类的。这些巨大的胡子。我想实际上如果你在野外看到卡多纳的胡子，也就是那样。是的，可能吧。如果一个制片人留着那样的胡子。哦，肯定的。
You'd raise an eyebrow. For sure. I mean, by the standards of Dom Johnson's, Oswald Mosley, Moustache. Yes. It's much larger than that. Yeah. But it's not as big as a Russian general. on the Eastern Front in 1914.
你会挑起眉毛的。肯定的。我的意思是，按照邓南遮、奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利的胡子标准。是的。它比那个大得多。是的。但它没有1914年东线俄罗斯将军的胡子那么大。
That's all I'm saying. No one will know what only this means, but that's fine. Let's just explain who Kodona is and where he comes from. He's from Turin. He was born in 1850. He's a very driven and prickly man. Mark Thompson, his brilliant book, The White War, says he's touchy, unforgiving and unsociable with a reputation for ferocious discipline and inflexibility.
我只是这么说。没人会知道这意味着什么，但这没关系。让我们解释一下卡多纳是谁以及他来自哪里。他来自都灵。他出生于1850年。他是一个非常有干劲且易怒的人。马克·汤普森在他出色的著作《白色战争》中说，他敏感、不宽容且不善交际，以严厉的纪律和僵化而闻名。
These are not things that massively endear him to us. disastrously for his men, Kordauna is obsessed by this idea of what he calls irresistible forward movement in battle. He's written only one thing in his life. And this is a pamphlet entitled Frontal Attack and Tactical Training, which he published in 1898. And basically because he's published this,
这些并不是让他深受我们喜爱的东西。对他的部下来说是灾难性的，卡多纳痴迷于他所谓的战斗中“不可抗拒的前进运动”的想法。他一生只写过一件事。这是一本题为《正面攻击与战术训练》的小册子，他在1898年出版。基本上因为他出版了这个，
he will never back down from the ideas within it. So he has not absorbed the lessons of the Russo-Japanese War. Of any recent war. Or indeed of the events on the Western Front. Not at all. So his plan is incredibly reckless. He says the left flank of our army will go through the Alps and it'll capture the Alps. Alpine passes leading to Austria.
他永远不会退缩其中的想法。所以他没有吸收日俄战争的教训。也没有吸收任何近期战争的教训。甚至没有吸收西线事件的教训。一点也没有。所以他的计划极其鲁莽。他说我们军队的左翼将穿过阿尔卑斯山，它将占领阿尔卑斯山。通往奥地利的阿尔卑斯山口。
The right flank of the army will capture Trieste and then Ljubljana and then Zagreb. Now, what is not taking to account is Italy's army is fairly useless to be completely frank. it's half the size of the armies of France and Germany. Most of the ordinary Italian soldiers can't read and write. They can barely understand each other's dialects, and they don't have enough guns, they don't have enough artillery. However, Codona is saying to his political bosses,
军队的右翼将占领的里雅斯特，然后是卢布尔雅那，然后是萨格勒布。现在，他没有考虑到的是，坦率地说，意大利的军队相当无用。它只有法德军队规模的一半。大多数普通的意大利士兵不会读写。他们几乎听不懂彼此的方言，而且他们没有足够的枪支，没有足够的火炮。然而，卡多纳正在对他的政治老板说，
with a fair wind, we will reach, quote, the heart of the Habsburg monarchy, which is to say Vienna, by the autumn. We'll be there. We will genuinely be there and done and dusted by Christmas. I mean, an absolutely ridiculous thing for him to say. The campaign starts badly, as you might expect, and it gets worse, because the Italian railways aren't really up to it.
如果运气好的话，我们将在秋天到达，引用，“哈布斯堡王朝的心脏”，也就是维也纳。我们会到那里的。我们真的会在圣诞节前到达那里并完成任务。我的意思是，他说出这样的话简直是荒谬。战役开始得很糟糕，正如你所料，而且情况变得更糟，因为意大利的铁路系统并不胜任。
The full mobilisation that was meant to take three weeks goes on for more than six weeks. We said that the Austrians are distracted by fighting Russia in the east. So this was Italy's moment. Italy actually outnumbered the Austrians four to one on their kind of common frontier. But because they're so slow and disorganised, they don't exploit their advantage at all. I mean, it's cheer up the Austrians up who've been completely useless so far in the war, haven't they? Yeah.
本应花费三周的全面动员持续了六个多星期。我们说过奥地利人被东线与俄罗斯的战斗分散了注意力。所以这是意大利的机会。意大利在共同边境上的人数实际上是奥地利人的四倍。但因为他们太慢且组织混乱，他们根本没有利用自己的优势。我的意思是，这让到目前为止在战争中完全无用的奥地利人感到振奋，不是吗？是的。
To find that they've got an enemy who are even worse than them. We're going to see the Austrians in a very different light in today's episode. The Austrians will appear to be the souls of sort of military competence. Martial competence, yeah. Exactly. So Codornas's initial target, he says, well, the first thing we'll do is we will cross the river Socha or Esonzo. Socho in Slovenian, Isonzo in Italian, which goes through the valleys of Westonzo. and Slovenia quite close to the border.
发现他们有一个比他们更糟糕的敌人。在今天的节目中，我们将以一种非常不同的眼光看待奥地利人。奥地利人将显得是军事能力的灵魂。军事能力，是的。没错。所以卡多纳最初的目标，他说，好吧，我们要做的第一件事就是跨越索查河或伊松佐河。索查在斯洛文尼亚语中，伊松佐在意大利语中，它流经伊松佐河谷。和斯洛文尼亚离边境很近。
I was actually there last summer, this part of the world. It's very beautiful, isn't it, Slovenia? Incredibly beautiful. Yeah. I mean, a brilliant place. I should be doing an advert for the Slovenian tourist board. Well, if the Slovenian tourist board are listening, I would love to go. I've always wanted to go.
去年夏天我实际上就在那里，世界的这一部分。非常美丽，不是吗，斯洛文尼亚？令人难以置信的美丽。是的。我的意思是，一个绝佳的地方。我应该为斯洛文尼亚旅游局做广告。好吧，如果斯洛文尼亚旅游局在听，我很想去。我一直想去。
I keep kind of mapping out, you know, fortnights when I could go and I never do. It's gorgeous. And it's, they've turned the whole thing, basically, into a First World War sort of tourist's attraction. So there are military cemeteries, there's amazing like trench networks and forts. You can roam around to your heart's content. It's a lot better than the Western Front because it's much more beautiful. It's brilliant, actually. I really recommend it.
我一直在规划，你知道，我可以去的两周时间，但我从来没去过。它太美了。而且他们把整个地方基本上变成了一个第一次世界大战的旅游景点。所以有军事公墓，有令人惊叹的战壕网络和堡垒。你可以随心所欲地漫游。它比西线好得多，因为它更美丽。它太棒了，实际上。我强烈推荐它。
And everything is really lovely. Light weather, nice people, great. But a very different scene back in 1915, right? Exactly, yes. Not if you're Italian in 1915. So basically, the Italians were meant to cross this river straight away. The Austrians blew up the bridges. It took the Italians ages to get across.
一切都非常可爱。天气好，人好，太棒了。但在1915年是一个非常不同的场景，对吧？没错，是的。如果你在1915年是意大利人就不是这样了。所以基本上，意大利人本应立即跨越这条河。奥地利人炸毁了桥梁。意大利人花了很长时间才跨过去。
By the time they get across, the Austrians are dug in on the mountains above. And this will be the focus of the campaign for the next two years. So the valley of this river, the Socha or the Azzonzo, and above it, the jagged kind of limestone highlands are what is called the cast or the casso. I mean, that's what you want to see when you were launching a full frontal attack. A jagged limestone highland. Yeah. Oh, God. Last episode we did the Western Front,
当他们跨过去时，奥地利人已经在上面的山上挖好了战壕。这将是未来两年战役的焦点。所以这条河的河谷，索查或伊松佐，以及它上方锯齿状的石灰岩高地，就是所谓的喀斯特地貌。我的意思是，当你发动全面正面攻击时，这就是你想看到的。锯齿状的石灰岩高地。是的。哦，天哪。上一集我们做了西线，
and you probably thought that sounded bad with all the mud and the lice and stuff. But at least it's flat. Yeah, this is much worse, much worse. So basically, in the summer, it is ridiculously hot. It's like the sun blazing down as you stagger up these kind of limestone hills. In the winter, it's ridiculously cold,
你可能认为那听起来很糟糕，有所有的泥浆和虱子之类的。但至少它是平坦的。是的，这更糟，更糟。所以基本上，在夏天，它热得离谱。就像太阳照在这些石灰岩山上，你蹒跚而行。在冬天，它冷得离谱，
the wind whipping in off the Adriatic or whatever. Because it's limestone, you can't really dig proper trenches. So you can dig a sort of little gully and lie down in this gully. And when bullets and shells hit the ground, they send up showers of fragments. Yeah, limestone shards in your eye. That's not what you want. Well, these shards would kill people half a mile away. Oh, God.
风从亚得里亚海吹来，诸如此类。因为它是石灰岩，你不能真正挖掘合适的战壕。所以你可以挖一个小沟，躺在这个沟里。当子弹和炮弹击中地面时，它们会溅起碎片。是的，石灰岩碎片进入你的眼睛。那不是你想要的。好吧，这些碎片会在半英里外杀死人。哦，天哪。
Yeah, if you're standing with your back to what's going on, half a mile away, this shard will hit you in the back of the head and that's the end of you. Do you remember in the previous series, I asked why the people didn't try and outflank the bottom of the Western Front by invading Switzerland? And I guess that this is the explanation, isn't it? Yeah. Don't go through mountains. No. So for the first few weeks, the Italians go extremely slowly.
是的，如果你背对着正在发生的事情站着，半英里外，这个碎片会击中你的后脑勺，那就是你的终点。你还记得在上一系列中，我问为什么人们不尝试通过入侵瑞士来绕过西线的底部吗？我想这就是解释，不是吗？是的。不要穿过山脉。不。所以最初的几周，意大利人走得非常慢。
They capture only a few villages and a few small towns. They lose 20,000 men in the first few weeks. They show absolutely no sign of having any conception of how they're going to take on machine guns and barbed wire and all this kind of thing. And Codona, General Codona with his nice moustache and whatnot, he looks at this and he says, well, I'm obviously not going to rethink my tactics because my tactics are excellent. What I should do is just start sacking generals. So in two years,
他们只占领了几个村庄和几个小镇。他们在最初的几周里损失了2万人。他们完全没有表现出任何关于如何应对机枪、铁丝网和所有这些东西的概念。而卡多纳，留着漂亮胡子的卡多纳将军，他看着这一切说，好吧，我显然不会重新考虑我的战术，因为我的战术非常出色。我应该做的是开始解雇将军。所以在两年内，
he launches what Mark Thompson calls a rolling purge of his officers. In two years, he sacks 217 generals, 255 colonels and 355 battalion commanders, which seems a lot to me, especially with already disorganized army. I mean, 217 generals, that's a lot of generals.
他发起了马克·汤普森所说的对他军官的“滚动清洗”。在两年内，他解雇了217名将军、255名上校和355名营长，这对我来说似乎很多，特别是在已经组织混乱的军队中。我的意思是，217名将军，那可是很多将军。
Yeah, I feel that Italians probably have too many. generals? Yeah, it's like the Royal Navy now with about 700 admirals and three ships. It's kind of on brand though for the Italians to have loads of generals there, isn't it? Yeah. There's a lot of gold braid, a lot of nice hats and feathers and stuff, I imagine. Yeah. Now, while the Italians are sacking their generals and basically trudging very slowly up these hills, the Austrians have been moving reinforcements to the front. Now, as we said, people will recall the Austrians have had an absolutely shocking start
是的，我觉得意大利人可能将军太多了？是的，就像现在的皇家海军，有大约700名海军上将和三艘船。不过，意大利人有那么多将军确实符合他们的品牌，不是吗？是的。我想有很多金色的编织，很多漂亮的帽子和羽毛之类的。是的。现在，当意大利人解雇他们的将军并基本上非常缓慢地蹒跚爬上这些山丘时，奥地利人一直在向前方调动增援部队。现在，正如我们所说，人们会记得奥地利人在战争初期有一个绝对令人震惊的开始
to the war. They made an absolute spectacle of themselves against Serbia. and basically ended up losing to Serbia, which is insane, given that that was the point of the whole war. Then they had a nightmare against Russia on the Eastern Front. You will recall a very, very fine moustache belonging to France, Conrad von Hutzendorf, the Austrian Supreme Commander. Is he the guy who is besotted with what's her name, Gina? Gina. That's why he started the war. And he basically starts the First World War just to impress her.
他们对塞尔维亚的表现简直是一场闹剧。基本上最终输给了塞尔维亚，这太疯狂了，考虑到那是整个战争的重点。然后他们在东线对俄罗斯的战斗中做了一场噩梦。你会记得弗朗茨·康拉德·冯·赫岑多夫，奥地利最高指挥官，留着非常非常漂亮的胡子。他就是那个痴迷于那个叫什么名字的人，吉娜？吉娜。这就是他发动战争的原因。他基本上发动第一次世界大战只是为了打动她。
Yes. He started the First World War as impressed Gina von Rininghouse. who is, ironically, Italian. Oh, I didn't know that. Yeah. Remember, Conrad from Hertzendorff had wanted to invade everybody, had demanded about 6,000 times to attack Austria's neighbours before the war finally started. By 1915, he's lost his youngest son on the Eastern Front,
是的。他发动第一次世界大战是为了打动吉娜·冯·里宁豪斯。她，讽刺的是，是意大利人。哦，我不知道。是的。记住，康拉德·冯·赫岑多夫曾想入侵所有人，在战争最终开始前曾要求大约6000次攻击奥地利的邻国。到1915年，他在东线失去了他最小的儿子，
and he's managed to mislay 800,000 men who've been killed, basically the entire pre-war Austro-Hungarian army. But this is the one thing that he gets right, the Italian campaign. Is Gina impressed? Must be very impressed. Even though he's fighting the Italians, her own people. I think by this point she's gone native a bit. But it's still tragic that the one thing he gets right is against Gina's countrymen.
而且他设法弄丢了80万名士兵，他们基本上被杀光了，整个战前的奥匈帝国军队。但这是他做对的一件事，意大利战役。吉娜被打动了吗？一定非常被打动。即使他是在与意大利人作战，她自己的人民。我想到了这一点，她已经有点“入乡随俗”了。但这仍然是悲剧，他做对的唯一一件事是针对吉娜的同胞。
Yeah, maybe, maybe. It's a tragedy there. So what he does is Conrad Franklin Hurststanov, he's finally learned the lessons. And he says, we're not going to attack. We're just going to be on the defensive. What we have, we hold. And he sends to defend the River Isonzo, the most senior South Slav officer in the Imperial Army. And Dominic, who is he and how do you pronounce his name?
是的，也许吧，也许吧。那里有一个悲剧。所以他所做的是，康拉德·冯·赫岑多夫，他终于吸取了教训。他说，我们不会进攻。我们只会处于防御状态。我们拥有的，我们守住。他派去保卫伊松佐河的是帝国军队中最高级的南斯拉夫军官。多米尼克，他是谁，你怎么发他的名字？
He is a name to conjure with Tom. He is General Svetazar Borreivich. Brilliant. So General Borreouevich is one of the outstanding generals of the First World War. And he is the embodiment of Austro-Hungarian multi-ethnic unity. Because he was born in Croatia to a Serbian Orthodox family. He joined the army when he was 10, went to cadet school. He was first decorated in the capture of,
他是一个值得一提的名字，汤姆。他是斯韦托扎尔·博罗耶维奇将军。太棒了。所以博罗耶维奇将军是第一次世界大战中最杰出的将军之一。他是奥匈帝国多民族统一的化身。因为他出生在克罗地亚的一个塞尔维亚东正教家庭。他10岁时加入军队，进入军校。他第一次获得勋章是在1878年波斯尼亚萨拉热窝的占领中。
Sarajevo in 1878 in Bosnia. And because he's a South Slav, yeah, because he's basically the embodiment of what will become Yugoslavia, he's really invested in this campaign because he's defending Slavic territory. He doesn't want to see the Italians. No. He doesn't have to seize all this. And most of his men, or at least a lot of his men, are Slovenians,
而且因为他是南斯拉夫人，是的，因为他基本上是后来成为南斯拉夫的化身，他真的投入到了这场战役中，因为他在保卫斯拉夫领土。他不想看到意大利人。不。他不必夺取所有这些。而且他的大多数部下，或者至少他的许多部下，是斯洛文尼亚人、
Croats and Bosnians. So they're also fighting for land that feels like theirs. So they're really invested in this. General Paul von Hindenberg, German walrus. He said of the Austro-Hungarians They fought the Russians with their head But fought the Italians with their whole soul And I guess that's because
克罗地亚人和波斯尼亚人。所以他们也在为感觉像是他们自己的土地而战。所以他们真的投入其中。保罗·冯·兴登堡将军，德国海象。他曾评价奥匈帝国人：他们用头脑与俄罗斯人作战，但用整个灵魂与意大利人作战。我想这是因为
They're not actually really Austro-Hungarians As you said They are Slavs defending a Slav homeland Exactly But also Borovic is a smart guy Like he's one of the generals Who's learned the lessons in the war He says, okay, what we'll do is
他们实际上并不是真正的奥匈帝国人，正如你所说，他们是保卫斯拉夫家园的斯拉夫人。没错。但博罗耶维奇也是个聪明人。就像他是那些吸取了战争教训的将军之一。他说，好吧，我们要做的就是
We'll get as high as we can We'll have five lines of barbed wire Let the Italians come when they come, wait until they're 100 yards away, only start firing then. If they ever break through, don't panic, keep your positions, I'll move up the reserves, I'll plug the gaps, we'll just stay calm, we'll let them come to us and we'll kill them all. And basically, this is what they do. So the first battle of the Asso, as it's called, is launched by the Italians on the 23rd of June, 1915.
我们会尽可能爬得高，我们会有五道铁丝网。让意大利人来，当他们来的时候，等到他们离我们100码远时，才开始开火。如果他们真的突破了，不要惊慌，保持你们的位置，我会调动预备队，我会堵住缺口，我们只会保持冷静，我们会让他们来找我们，然后我们会把他们全部杀掉。基本上，这就是他们所做的。所以伊松佐第一次战役，正如它所称，是由意大利人在1915年6月23日发起的。
And think of this river, it's running just inside the border of Slovenia, so in the, to the east of Italy. And the Italians throw in more than 200,000 men, which is more than twice as many as the Austrians have got. And the Italians think, well, this will go, this will be great. And actually, what happens? They charge uphill and the Austrians open fire with their machine guns, and loads and loads of Italians are killed straight away. So I'll give you an example, an account by an Italian officer called Renato di Stolfe. And he's describing an attack on a mountain called Monte Samichelle. Dyshtolfo is meant to be leading his men into battle with a pistol.
想想这条河，它就在斯洛文尼亚边境内，也就是在意大利的东部。意大利人投入了超过20万名士兵，这是奥地利人人数的两倍多。意大利人认为，好吧，这会很顺利，这会很棒。实际上，发生了什么？他们冲上山坡，奥地利人用机枪开火，大量的意大利人立即被杀。所以我给你举个例子，一个叫雷纳托·迪·斯托尔法的意大利军官的叙述。他正在描述对一座叫蒙特·萨米切尔的山的攻击。迪·斯托尔法本应带着手枪带领他的部下投入战斗。
They've run out of pistols, so he only has his sword. It starts raining as soon as they set off, so they're all completely sodden and waterlogged. They draw their swords, there's a band, they're shouting, Savoy, which is their kind of war cry at the house of Savoy. They start to go off uphill. They're all carrying backpacks that are 35 kilograms in weight. What are they taking?
他们的手枪用完了，所以他只有他的剑。他们一出发就开始下雨，所以他们全都湿透了。他们拔出剑，有乐队，他们在大喊“萨伏伊”，这是他们对萨伏伊王室的某种战吼。他们开始上山。他们每个人都背着35公斤重的背包。他们带了什么？
Potts, I don't know, pasta. Are they eating pasta by this point? Or isn't that invented by Americans in 1958? In 1964. Yeah, invented in St. Louis, Missouri. Isn't that the way with all Italian dishes? I gather so. That's what I vaguely remember.
锅，我不知道，意大利面。他们到这个时候在吃意大利面吗？还是那不是美国人在1958年发明的？在1964年。是的，在密苏里州圣路易斯发明的。所有的意大利菜不都是这样吗？我收集到的是这样。这就是我模糊记得的。
No, but 35 kilograms. You know when you check into a plane? Yeah, I know. And the maximum is 23 or something. I wouldn't want to be charging Austrian machine gun placements. You know, with limestone shards going everywhere. You've got the weight of two suitcases, two full suitcases on your back, staggering up this lime.
不，但是35公斤。你知道当你办理登机手续时？是的，我知道。最大重量是23公斤左右。我可不想冲向奥地利的机枪阵地。你知道，到处都是石灰岩碎片。你的背上有两个手提箱，两个满载的手提箱的重量，蹒跚爬上这个石灰岩。
It's raining. Soon the sun's going to come out and then you'll be steaming or whatever. What the hell are they taking? Anyway, they stagger up this hill. Then the Austrians start shooting at them. Most of the officers were killed straight away. The men are all scrambling around on the hands and knees take cover. And De Stolfo said, in a whirl of death and glory,
下着雨。很快太阳就会出来，然后你会冒蒸汽之类的。他们到底带了什么？总之，他们蹒跚爬上这座山。然后奥地利人开始向他们射击。大多数军官立即被杀。男人们都在手脚并用地爬行寻找掩护。迪·斯托尔法说，在死亡与荣耀的漩涡中，
within a few moments, Arabic Garibaldian style of warfare is crushed and consigned to the shadows of history. And basically there's then another rainstorm which stops the battle and the Italian survivors sort of stagger back down the hill with their backpacks and they're backed where they started. And this is the story of the entire first battle of the Asso. It takes two weeks. The Italians make about two yards and they take 15,000 casualties. That's the first battle of the Asso.
在几分钟内，阿拉伯式的加里波第式战争风格被粉碎并被送进了历史的阴影中。基本上随后又下了一场雨，停止了战斗，意大利幸存者背着背包蹒跚走下山，回到了他们开始的地方。这就是伊松佐第一次战役的全部故事。它持续了两周。意大利人推进了大约两码，伤亡了1.5万人。这就是伊松佐第一次战役。
And how many are they going to be over the course of the war? There's going to be 11 more of them. You would think if you were General Kodona, you would say, well, that didn't work. I probably won't try that again. He tries it 11 more times in the next two years or so. Well, he's written his book. He has written his book. But also, while this was happening, he was at a conference with the Allied generals, the British and the French.
在战争过程中会有多少次？还会有11次。如果你是卡多纳将军，你会认为，好吧，那没用。我可能不会再试一次了。他在接下来的两年左右又试了11次。好吧，他写了他的书。他确实写了他的书。但同时，当这一切发生时，他正在与盟军将军，英国人和法国人开会。
And they said to him, we want you to, you know, if now you've entered the war, We've given you this money and these promises. You need to produce results. So he feels under pressure. And so less than two weeks later, he launches the second battle of the Asonzo, again in the Sochia Valley. Same story. Up the hill they go, cut down by Austrian machine guns. And they haven't advanced at all.
他们对他说，我们希望你，你知道，既然你现在已经参战了，我们给了你这些钱和这些承诺。你需要拿出结果。所以他感到压力很大。于是不到两周后，他发起了伊松佐第二次战役，再次在索查河谷。同样的故事。他们上山，被奥地利机枪扫射。他们根本没有推进。
I mean, barely. I mean, you know, if you've got really into the weeds of this, you'll find they've actually captured a village or something. A village, a hill here, a hill there. But in the grand scheme of things, they've made no progress whatsoever. The sun has come out. It's now the height of summer. There are these amazing accounts from officers in Mark Thompson's book. There's no escaping the heat. Tongues swell, coated with thick saliva. Fingers swell and dangle clumsily from sticky hands, eyes inflamed, skin like parchment. And he also quotes an Italian officer called Vaglio Bonamore, who kept a diary in the first month
我的意思是，几乎没有。我的意思是，你知道，如果你真的深入研究这个，你会发现他们实际上占领了一个村庄之类的。一个村庄，一座山，又一座山。但在大局中，他们根本没有任何进展。太阳出来了。现在是盛夏。马克·汤普森的书中有这些令人惊叹的军官叙述。没有办法逃避酷热。舌头肿胀，覆盖着厚厚的唾液。手指肿胀，从粘糊糊的手上笨拙地垂下，眼睛发炎，皮肤像羊皮纸。他还引用了一位叫瓦格里奥·博纳莫雷的意大利军官的话，他在战争的第一个月写了日记。
of the war. Bonamore says, you know, he describes being in one of these limestone trenches. We talked about the trenches on the Western Front last time. The Italian trenches are awful. They are far worse than anything on the Western family. Because they can't dig down deep enough, really for them to be effective. They can't dig down. You can't bury the bodies. Yeah. So the bodies are just hanging around. The stench was unbearable, says Bonomore. We're squatting among our own and enemy corpses. Basically, you can't get very deep. So when the
博纳莫雷说，你知道，他描述了在这些石灰岩战壕中的情景。我们上次谈到了西线的战壕。意大利的战壕很糟糕。它们比西线上的任何东西都要糟糕得多。因为他们无法挖得足够深，真的无法有效。他们无法深挖。你无法掩埋尸体。是的。所以尸体就在周围。博纳莫雷说，恶臭令人难以忍受。我们蹲在自己和敌人的尸体中间。基本上，你无法挖得很深。所以当
Austrians fire at you, lots of you end up dying, blokes are being ripped open by shells and whatnot. And he gives us a description of a single day on the Upper Sotcha River on 14th of August gives you a sense of what it's like So the Italians started with an artillery bombardment at 3 o'clock in the morning
奥地利人向你开火时，你们很多人最终会死，家伙们被炮弹撕裂之类的。他给了我们8月14日在上索查河的一天的描述，让你感觉到那是什么样子。所以意大利人在凌晨3点开始了炮击。
and they set off uphill Before they even really started uphill Most of them were absolutely exhausted And some of them while they're walking Fet asleep while they were walking Which seems a bit much The sun finally comes up And they discover that they're on this hillside
他们在真正开始上山之前就出发了。他们大多数人已经精疲力竭。有些人甚至在走路时睡着了，这似乎有点过分。太阳终于出来了。他们发现自己在山坡上。
They're totally exposed, no cover They're exposed to the Austrian guns The Austrians fire at them And kind of rake them with shrapnel But that goes on until midday. And at midday their officer says, OK, charge now. They start charging.
他们完全暴露，没有掩护。他们暴露在奥地利的枪口下。奥地利人向他们开火，用弹片扫射他们。但这一直持续到中午。中午时分，他们的军官说，好吧，现在冲锋。他们开始冲锋。
The people who've got the wire cutters are all shot down before they even get to the barbed wire. So the rest of the men then are underneath the barbed wire and the Austrian machine guns are just firing at them. Bonomori, the dead are in piles
那些拿着剪线钳的人在到达铁丝网之前就被射杀了。所以剩下的士兵都在铁丝网下，奥地利机枪只是向他们开火。博纳莫雷，死者堆成了堆。
on top of each other. Nearly all the senior officers have fallen. And basically they end up huddling for hours together, kind of underneath the Austrian barbed wire. They can't get through it. They can't go back. They're kind of stuck. They all run out of ammo and their captain says, I think we should just make a break through. We should try to sneak away. And so they start to sneak away. The first four men who try to sneak away are all shot straight away. Actually, let's not sneak away. This is a really bad idea. So they basically just stay there
彼此堆叠在一起。几乎所有的资深军官都阵亡了。他们基本上只能蜷缩在一起好几个小时，躲在奥地利的铁丝网下。他们无法穿过铁丝网，也无法撤退。他们就这样被困住了。他们的弹药耗尽了，队长说，我想我们应该突围。我们应该试着溜走。于是他们开始尝试溜走。最先尝试溜走的四个人立刻就被射杀了。实际上，还是别溜走了。这真是个糟糕的主意。所以他们基本上就待在那里
under the Austrian wire until darkness comes. And then when darkness comes, when the Austrians have kind of gone to bed or whatever, they managed to stumble down the hill. And Bonamore is in his diary, what a massacre. How many young lives wasted? It's raining nonstop and we lie in the bottom of a ravine to spend the night amid the water and the cold. And the amazing detail about all this, about these battles that always sticks in my mind. It's very unusual in the story of the First World War. There are loads of stories about the Austrian saying to the Italians, go back, we won't shoot at you, you know, don't kill yourselves for nothing. So here's an example, an Austrian captain shouting to his machine gunners.
待在奥地利的铁丝网下，直到天黑。当夜幕降临，奥地利人去睡觉或者干别的去了，他们才设法跌跌撞撞地走下山坡。博纳莫尔在日记中写道，真是场大屠杀。有多少年轻的生命被浪费了？雨一直在下，我们躺在峡谷底部，在寒冷和积水中度过了一夜。关于这一切，关于这些战斗，最让我印象深刻的一个惊人细节是，这在第一次世界大战的故事中非常罕见。有很多关于奥地利人对意大利人说，回去吧，我们不会向你们开枪，你们知道，别为了毫无意义的事情送死。这里就有一个例子，一位奥地利队长对着他的机枪手大喊。
He says to them, what do you want to do? Do you want to kill them all? Let them be. And then he says to the Italians, stop, go back. We won't shoot anymore. Do you want everyone to die?
他对他们说，你们想干什么？你们想把他们全杀了吗？放过他们吧。然后他对意大利人说，停下，回去吧。我们不会再开枪了。你们想让所有人都死吗？
Loads of accounts of Austrians saying, Italians, go back. We don't want to massacre you. Your brave men don't get yourselves killed like this. And there's even a story from later in the year. The Austrians actually stopped firing during a battle. And they said to the Italians, go on.
有很多关于奥地利人说，意大利人，回去吧。我们不想屠杀你们。你们这些勇敢的人，别这样送死。甚至还有后来发生的一件事。奥地利人在战斗中真的停止了射击。他们对意大利人说，走吧。
Enough. Get your dead and go back down. And as the Italians were collecting all their dead, the Austrians came out from behind their machine guns to help them to bring them stretches and cigarettes. And the Italians gave them some of their feathers from their plumed hats as nice souvenirs. God, they're still wearing plumed hats after all this. They're still wearing their plumed hats. I mean, what are they thinking? So that was the second battle.
够了。带上你们的死者回去吧。当意大利人正在收敛他们的死者时，奥地利人从机枪阵地后面走出来，帮他们搬运担架，还给他们香烟。意大利人则送给他们一些羽毛帽上的羽毛作为纪念品。天哪，经历了这一切他们还在戴羽毛帽。他们还在戴着羽毛帽。我是说，他们在想什么？这就是第二次战斗。
The second battle was a massive bloodbath. The Italians lost 42,000 men. The Austrians actually lost more, 50,000. So here is the question. It's been agitating Callum, our producer. Yeah. How come the Austrians actually lost more? Because they're outnumbered.
第二次战斗是一场巨大的血腥屠杀。意大利人损失了42000人。奥地利人损失得更多，有50000人。那么问题来了。这让我们的制片人卡勒姆很困扰。是的。为什么奥地利人反而损失更多？因为他们人数处于劣势。
And because the Italians, when they finally do get their act together, they're able to overrun some Austrian positions. But they aren't able to do enough of that to swing the tide of the battle. But, I mean, let's not pretend that the Austrians aren't being, the Austrians are being killed too in large numbers. You know, the Austrians, they're not exactly one of Europe's great military machines. We saw how badly they performed against the Russians. they are struggling, but somehow they're clinging on, is the answer. Right. So they are the massive underdogs here, even though they're atop of the hill.
而且因为意大利人，当他们最终协调一致时，他们能够攻占一些奥地利人的阵地。但他们无法做到足够多来扭转战局。但是，我是说，我们不要假装奥地利人没有被杀，奥地利人也损失惨重。你知道，奥地利人，他们算不上欧洲伟大的军事机器之一。我们看到了他们对抗俄国人时表现得有多糟糕。他们很挣扎，但不知何故他们还在坚持，这就是答案。没错。所以他们在这里是处于绝对劣势的一方，尽管他们占据着山顶。
But this slightly recalibrates the strategy then, because it does suggest that, albeit bloodly, it is working. And if the Austrians are as outnumbered as they seem to be. One day it will work. One day it would work. I mean, you can kind of see. Kodon's mentality. General Kodorn has spin doctor joins us now on there.
但这稍微调整了战略，因为它确实表明，尽管血腥，但它是有效的。如果奥地利人确实像看起来那样人数处于劣势。总有一天会成功的。总有一天会成功的。我是说，你可以看出卡多纳的心态。卡多纳将军的公关人员现在加入了我们。
rest of history. Yeah, but it doesn't work, though. I mean, I would say it doesn't work. Well, we'll see. We'll see. I think the fact that the Italians, despite all this, are losing fewer men than the Austrians, does put a slightly different perspective on it. But they're not always losing fewer men.
剩下的就是历史了。是的，但这并没有奏效。我是说，我会说它没有奏效。好吧，我们走着瞧。我们走着瞧。我认为意大利人尽管经历了这一切，损失的人数却比奥地利人少，这确实提供了一个略有不同的视角。但他们并不总是损失更少的人。
So back in Rome, Salandra, the prime minister, is becoming very frustrated. He needs a victory to show the Italian public, but he also needs a victory to appease the Allies. So in October, General Kodona agrees to launch. a third battle of the Asso and it starts with a huge bombardment in October the 18th. Not enough as always to break the Austrian
回到罗马，首相萨兰德拉变得非常沮丧。他需要一场胜利来向意大利公众展示，但他同时也需要一场胜利来安抚盟友。因此在十月，卡多纳将军同意发动第三次伊松佐河战役，战斗始于10月18日的一场大规模炮击。像往常一样，这不足以突破奥地利的
defences or destroy their belted wire. The Italians advanced to driving rain. Two weeks it's really muddy, they don't really get anywhere and that's that and at the end of that third battle the Italians lost maybe 67,000
防御或摧毁他们的铁丝网。意大利人在连绵不断的雨中推进。两周时间里到处都是泥泞，他们实际上没取得什么进展，事情就是这样。在那场第三次战役结束时，意大利人损失了大约67000
men killed and wounded but in this case only 40,000 Austrians. So the tide of war is turning. Well, now you would think at this point, Kodona would surely change tactics, but no, he looks at the calendar, he says,
人伤亡，但在这种情况下，奥地利人只有40000人伤亡。所以战争的局势正在转变。好吧，现在你可能会认为在这一点上，卡多纳肯定会改变战术，但没有，他看了看日历，他说，
well, that's probably time for a fourth battle before the end of the year. And he's convinced the Austrians must be running out of men now. And he's not entirely wrong because in some places the Italians outnumber the Austrians
好吧，在年底前可能还有时间进行第四次战役。他确信奥地利人现在一定快没兵了。他并不完全错误，因为在某些地方，意大利人的人数是奥地利人的
three to one. So he launches a fourth battle. At this point, it's now very cold. Lots of the Italians have got frostbite. Their feet are so swollen on with frostbite. They can't put their boots on. The hands are all purple and misshapen with the cold. Lots of Italians by now started to shoot themselves to get out of the war. So given the choice,
三倍。于是他发动了第四次战役。此时，天气已经非常寒冷。许多意大利士兵患上了冻疮。他们的脚因为冻疮肿得厉害，连靴子都穿不上。他们的手因为寒冷而变得青紫畸形。到目前为止，许多意大利人开始自杀以逃离战争。所以如果让你选择，
you would rather be fighting at the Battle of Luce than in this battle. Yeah, I think so. I think so. Because here's the test. When Allied observers went to the Italian lines, they said, oh my God, I didn't think anything could be worse than what we're experiencing, but this is absolutely awful. So in that fourth battle, by the way, the Italians lost 49,000 men, the Austrians 30,000. So again, the Italians lost more. And the conditions in the Italian trenches over the winter were absolutely appalling. They have these shallow trenches, their uniforms are in rags, a lot of them don't even have guns, their boots fall apart. They've all got typhoid and cholera.
你宁愿在卢斯战役中战斗，也不愿参加这场战斗。是的，我想是的。我想是的。因为这是考验。当盟军观察员来到意大利防线时，他们说，天哪，我没想到还有比我们经历的更糟糕的事情，但这简直太可怕了。顺便说一句，在第四次战役中，意大利人损失了49000人，奥地利人损失了30000人。所以意大利人再次损失更多。冬天意大利战壕里的条件简直糟透了。他们的战壕很浅，制服破烂不堪，很多人甚至没有枪，靴子也散架了。他们都患上了伤寒和霍乱。
And actually, the thing that I was about to say amuses me, It both appalls and amuses me. British visitors who went to the Italian camps so they couldn't get over the toilet conditions. They had no respect for Italian hygiene. One British visitor said the Italian camp was literally a field of filth. I had never seen such a disgusting sight, and I wondered what kind of epidemic was being bred
实际上，我正要说的一件事让我觉得很有趣，它既让我震惊又让我觉得好笑。去过意大利军营的英国访客说他们无法忍受那里的厕所条件。他们对意大利人的卫生状况毫无敬意。一位英国访客说，意大利军营简直就是一片污秽之地。我从未见过如此令人作呕的景象，我怀疑那里正在滋生什么样的流行病
amidst the excretor and soiled paper. It sounds like a kind of Bidica discussing Italian toilet arrangements in 1897 or something. something. They're always very sniffy about that. Or a columnist in the Daily Telegraph whose children have just been to Glastonbury. Yes. And it's appalled by the... Yeah. When he went to see how they were getting on.
在排泄物和弄脏的纸张之间。这听起来像是1897年某个比迪卡在讨论意大利的厕所安排之类的东西。他们总是对此非常挑剔。或者像《每日电讯报》的一位专栏作家，他的孩子们刚去过格拉斯顿伯里音乐节。是的。他对……感到震惊。当他去看看他们过得怎么样时。
Anyway, so the year ends with the war in total deadlock at an absolutely horrendous cost. So the Italians have now lost, killed and wounded. 400,000 men. And this is a war that they chose, right? They could have stayed out. but they've thrown away the lives of all these people. And Mark Thompson gives the example of a single brigade who were called, unimprovably,
总之，这一年以战争陷入彻底的僵局而告终，代价极其惨重。意大利人现在已经损失了40万伤亡人员。这是一场他们自己选择的战争，对吧？他们本可以置身事外，但他们却抛弃了所有这些人的生命。马克·汤普森举了一个单一旅的例子，他们被称为，无法改进的，
the Palenta Brigade because they wore yellow colours. And the Palenta Brigade began the war with 130 officers and 6,000 soldiers. And by the end of 1915, having been reinforced several times, they have lost 154 officers and 4,276 men killed, wounded and wounded. missing. So almost the entire pre-war contingent. And so by the end of the year,
帕伦塔旅，因为他们穿着黄色的制服。帕伦塔旅在战争开始时有130名军官和6000名士兵。到1915年底，在经过几次增援后，他们损失了154名军官和4276名士兵，包括阵亡、受伤和失踪。几乎是战前整个部队的人数。所以到年底，
the Italians have actually lost more than the Austrians, do you think? Yes, they have. And just to look ahead, in the next two years, they fight another eight battles on the Asso. And basically the 12th of them, the Italians just crack completely, and the Austrians end up winning it.
意大利人实际上损失得比奥地利人多，你觉得呢？是的，确实如此。展望未来，在接下来的两年里，他们在伊松佐河又打了八场战役。基本上到了第12次，意大利人彻底崩溃了，奥地利人最终赢得了胜利。
And this is that place called Cobarid, very pretty town actually. Caporetto, Hemingway was there towards the end of the war. This is when he writes about the Italian front, he's writing about Caporetto. And the Italian second army was completely destroyed. And the Austrians and the Germans, who have now piled in to help the Austrians, they pushed them back and they struck a hundred miles into Italy. And then the Austrians themselves then fell apart. The Italians rallied at the river Piave, and then they beat the Austrians at Vittoria, Venetian.
这就是那个叫科巴里德的地方，实际上是个很漂亮的小镇。卡波雷托，海明威在战争末期就在那里。这就是他写意大利前线时所写的，他写的是卡波雷托。意大利第二集团军被彻底摧毁了。奥地利人和德国人，他们现在加入进来帮助奥地利人，他们把意大利人推了回去，并深入意大利境内一百英里。然后奥地利人自己也崩溃了。意大利人在皮亚韦河重整旗鼓，然后在维托里奥·维内托击败了奥地利人。
in November of 1918, and this was the point at which the Austro-Hungarian Empire was falling apart. And then the war ends, and at that point, the Italians have lost 689,000 people killed in battle, as well as probably about 600,000 civilians and another million Italians seriously wounded. So it goes well. Yeah, exactly developed to their advantage.
在1918年11月，这就是奥匈帝国分崩离析的时刻。然后战争结束了，在那一点上，意大利人损失了689000人在战斗中阵亡，还有大约60万平民和另外一百万意大利人受重伤。所以进展顺利。是的，完全符合他们的利益。
And it's this tremendous national trauma. And the thing is, for what? because at the peace conferences they are given Trieste they're given Istria they're given the Trentino and South Tyrol but they're not given a lot of the other stuff they wanted they don't get a bit of Turkey
这是一种巨大的民族创伤。问题是，为了什么？因为在和平会议上，他们得到了的里雅斯特、伊斯特拉、特伦蒂诺和南蒂罗尔，但他们没有得到他们想要的很多其他东西，他们没有得到土耳其的一部分，
they don't get loads of Greek islands they don't get Dalmatia they don't get an empire in the Adriatic and even though on paper they are among the winners of the First World War lots of Italians feel we've actually you know we did all that for nothing you know we didn't get what we wanted
他们没有得到大量的希腊岛屿，他们没有得到达尔马提亚，他们没有在亚得里亚海建立帝国，即使在纸面上他们是第一次世界大战的获胜者之一，许多意大利人觉得我们实际上，你知道，我们所做的一切都是徒劳的，你知道，我们没有得到我们想要的。
and so this will feed into the feeling of resentment that will help to incubate fascism? Completely. So one of the people who feels cheated is one of the worst men in history, Gabriela de Dancio. And he has all the through the war, he's been reveling in the war.
所以这会助长那种将有助于孕育法西斯主义的怨恨情绪吗？完全是这样。所以其中一个感到被欺骗的人是历史上最糟糕的人之一，加布里埃尔·邓南遮。他在整个战争期间，一直沉浸在战争中。
I mean, he was nicknamed the poets of slaughter, and he loved that nickname. And when the war ends, because they don't get the Istrian port of Rieca, or Fume, as the Italians called it, he seizes it himself
我是说，他被称为屠杀诗人，他很喜欢这个绰号。当战争结束时，因为他们没有得到伊斯特拉的里耶卡港，或者意大利人称之为菲乌梅的港口，他亲自夺取了它，
with a paramanitary group and he names himself the duchee. And that, of course, is an inspiration for another man we've mentioned, the man who really does tap the bitterness after Italy's war, a man who had fought on the asso, who rose to become a corporal, who was badly wounded but survived to tell the tale, and that man was Benito Mussolini. Okay, Dominic, well, next week we will be leaving the killing fields of the isonzo
带着一个准军事组织，他自称为领袖。当然，这启发了我们提到的另一个人，那个真正利用了意大利战后痛苦的人，一个曾在伊松佐河战斗过，晋升为下士，受过重伤但幸存下来讲述故事的人，那个人就是贝尼托·墨索里尼。好吧，多米尼克，下周我们将离开伊松佐河的杀戮场，
and heading out onto the high seas for the story of the Lusitania. In a way, a sequel, not just to this series, but to the series we did on Titanic, because it involves more death on the high seas. And then after that, we will be going to Brussels for a spy story. Or was Edith Cavell a spy? We will be exploring that. Restis History Club members, of course, can hear both those episodes and the remaining two episodes, which will be on Gallipoli. So to join them and get the full range of benefits, the only way to do that is to go to the restishistory.com and sign up there. So thank you, Dominic. Thank you everyone for listening.
前往公海，讲述卢西塔尼亚号的故事。在某种程度上，这不仅是这个系列的续集，也是我们制作的泰坦尼克号系列的续集，因为它涉及公海上更多的死亡。在那之后，我们将前往布鲁塞尔讲述一个间谍故事。或者伊迪丝·卡维尔是间谍吗？我们将探讨这个问题。历史俱乐部成员当然可以听到这两集以及剩下的两集，这两集将关于加里波利。所以要加入他们并获得全部福利，唯一的方法就是去therestishistory.com注册。谢谢你，多米尼克。谢谢大家的收听。
We will be back soon. Bye-bye. Ciao, Rivedecchi. Hi, everybody. We are back with another absolutely colossal update about the Rest is History Festival. Well, it's massive. So on the 4th and 5th of July, we will be at Hampton Court Palace. that we have a weekend of brilliant talks, live music, exclusive access to historic Royal Palace's collections, and yes, Dominic, most exciting of all, this is the thing I have been pushing for, and I'm so looking forward to it. We have medieval combat, a terrifying, brutal, yet completely thrilling sport. It is going to be an unforgettable two days.
我们很快会回来。再见。Ciao, Arrivederci。大家好。我们带着关于“历史的其余部分”节日的另一个绝对巨大的更新回来了。嗯，规模很大。所以7月4日和5日，我们将在汉普顿宫。我们有一个周末的精彩讲座、现场音乐、独家参观历史悠久的皇家宫殿收藏，是的，多米尼克，最令人兴奋的是，这是我一直推动的事情，我非常期待。我们有中世纪格斗，这是一项恐怖、残酷但又完全令人兴奋的运动。这将是令人难忘的两天。
It is indeed. And at the core of the festival of these talks, we've got some more talks to add to the lineup. So I will be talking about. talking to the brilliant Tudor historian Tracy Borman about the secrets of the six wives of Henry the 8th. I'll be talking to a friend of the show and Irish National Treasure, Paul Rouse, about whether there is an alternative universe in which islands could have remained part of the United Kingdom. We'll be talking to Katja Hoyer about Weimar, Germany, and in particular, the town of Weimar through history. And Professor Adam Smith will be telling the story of America through three presidents. And on top of all that, I'll be doing a special event with Ian Hislop about the history of satire.
确实如此。在这些讲座的节日核心，我们还有更多讲座要加入阵容。所以我将谈论。与杰出的都铎历史学家特蕾西·博曼谈论亨利八世六位妻子的秘密。我将与节目的朋友和爱尔兰国宝保罗·劳斯谈论是否存在一个爱尔兰可能仍然是联合王国一部分的替代宇宙。我们将与卡佳·霍耶谈论魏玛德国，特别是历史上的魏玛镇。亚当·史密斯教授将通过三位总统讲述美国的故事。最重要的是，我将与伊恩·希斯洛普一起举办一场关于讽刺历史的特别活动。
And I will be on stage with Mary Beard and we will be talking about just how strange, just how alien, just how different to us Rome was or maybe it wasn't. I will be talking to Helen Castor about Elizabeth I. And we'll be discussing whether she truly was England's greatest ruler or maybe whether that title should still be claimed by Athelstan. I will be talking to Ali Ansari about all things Persian, with Dan Jackson about the pit of death. And I will be talking to a friend of the show, Willie Dalrymple, about the links between ancient India and Greece and Rome. Absolutely incredible scenes. And of course, on both days, Tom and I will be on stage doing a show together as well. So on the first day, we'll be answering all our club members' questions.
我将与玛丽·比尔德同台，我们将讨论罗马是多么奇怪，多么陌生，多么与我们不同，或者也许并非如此。我将与海伦·卡斯托谈论伊丽莎白一世。我们将讨论她是否真的是英国最伟大的统治者，或者那个头衔是否应该仍然由埃塞尔斯坦拥有。我将与阿里·安萨里谈论波斯的一切，与丹·杰克逊谈论死亡之坑。我将与节目的朋友威利·达尔林普尔谈论古代印度与希腊和罗马之间的联系。绝对令人难以置信的场景。当然，在这两天里，汤姆和我也会一起在舞台上表演。所以第一天，我们将回答我们所有俱乐部成员的问题。
and then to close the festival, we will do a definitive ranking of the all-time top friends of the show. So lots to look forward to. And beyond that, there is so much else that will be happening across the weekend. So think of it as the ultimate summer history hangout. And your tickets will give you full access
然后为了结束节日，我们将对有史以来最好的节目朋友进行最终排名。所以有很多值得期待的事情。除此之外，整个周末还会发生很多其他事情。所以把它想象成终极的夏季历史聚会。你的门票将让你完全进入
to explore the great Tudor Palace of Hampton Court and indeed the Royal Tennis Court. So that would be very exciting. There will be food and food. drink fit for a king, which sounds very enticing. I picture the very glamorous people that are our club members in their summer garb. They're on the lawn at Hampton Court Palace. They're chatting about history and delightful surroundings, sipping on a refreshing gin and tonic. And it's probably the most civilised festival there's ever been. I mean, that's what I imagine anyway. Just a
探索汉普顿宫的伟大都铎宫殿，甚至是皇家网球场。所以那会非常令人兴奋。会有适合国王的食物和饮料，听起来非常诱人。我想象着我们那些穿着夏装的俱乐部成员是多么迷人。他们在汉普顿宫的草坪上。他们在愉快的环境中聊天谈论历史，啜饮着清爽的金汤力。这可能是史上最文明的节日了。我是说，这就是我的想象。只是一个
reminder, the tickets are exclusive to club members and if you are not a member, now is the perfect time to join. So head over to The Restishistory.com to sign up and grab your tickets and of course have access to a whole range of supplementary benefits. Once you have signed up to the restishistory.com, all you do then is log into the members area and you select festival and it's all very obvious. But you know what? There is a twist. If you do this, you will be entered into a genuinely unbelievable prize draw. And that prize draw, if you win, you and three other people, it's like the golden tickets in Charlie in the Chocolate Factory,
提醒，门票是俱乐部成员专享的，如果你还不是会员，现在是加入的最佳时机。所以前往TheRestishistory.com注册并抢购门票，当然还可以获得一系列补充福利。一旦你注册了therestishistory.com，你所要做的就是登录会员区并选择节日，一切都非常明显。但你知道吗？有一个转折。如果你这样做，你将参加一个真正令人难以置信的抽奖。那个抽奖，如果你赢了，你和其他三个人，就像《查理和巧克力工厂》里的金票一样，
because you will be given the chance to be upgraded to the premium experience. And the premium experience will give you, among other things, unlimited food and drink for free all day. Do not miss it. Can't wait to see you there. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因为你将有机会升级到高级体验。高级体验将为你提供，除其他事项外，全天无限量免费食物和饮料。不要错过。迫不及待地想在那里见到你。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。